In Toronto, every arrival is a statement, and nothing says it better than this.
Cadillac Optic was the number one selling luxury EV in Canada for 2025.
Find your rhythm across a seamless 33-inch display and an immersive 19-speaker AKG surround audio system.
This city demands agility, and Optic delivers with precision to make every drive extraordinary.
Let's take the Cadillac.
Find out more at Cadillac Canada.ca.
Luxury sales claim based on S&P Global Mobility Canadian New Vehicle Total Registrations for calendar year 2025 for the Cadillac definition of luxury.
This episode is brought to you by Accenture.
在多伦多，每一次抵达都是一种宣言，而没有什么比这更能说明问题了。凯迪拉克 Optic 是 2025 年加拿大销量第一的豪华电动汽车。通过无缝的 33 英寸显示屏和沉浸式的 19 扬声器 AKG 环绕音响系统，找到属于你的节奏。这座城市需要灵活性，而 Optic 以精准的表现让每一次驾驶都非同凡响。让我们开凯迪拉克吧。在 Cadillac Canada.ca 了解更多信息。豪华车销量声明基于标普全球移动（S&P Global Mobility）2025 日历年加拿大新车总注册量，符合凯迪拉克的豪华定义。本集由埃森哲（Accenture）赞助播出。
When your advertising operations fall out of sync, everything else follows.
Spotify and Accenture are working together to reinvent the rhythm of ad sales,
using automation, analytics, and smarter workflows to simplify campaign delivery
and access better data across the business.
The result?
Less time spent on operations, more time connecting brands with the moments and fandoms that matter most.
Learn more at Accenture.com slash Spotify.
Welcome back to our second drink of lecture circuit, part one.
当你的广告运营不同步时，其他一切都会随之受影响。Spotify 和埃森哲正在合作重塑广告销售的节奏，利用自动化、分析和更智能的工作流程来简化广告投放，并获取整个业务中更好的数据。结果如何？减少在运营上花费的时间，腾出更多时间将品牌与最重要的时刻和粉丝群体联系起来。在 Accenture.com/Spotify 了解更多。欢迎回到我们的《讲座巡回》第二部分，第一集。
I'm going to start with this fan question from Melinda D in Austin, Texas.
Hi, ladies. I love the opening scene where Michael is on the intercom saying ridiculous things.
Were there any candy bag alts for this? Thanks. Love the podcast.
Okay. So, Melinda, I love this cold open too. And Jim has that great line that sets it up where he says,
this morning the phone guy comes in and he shows Michael that the phones have a
PA function. And then he just left. Yes. And then Michael does all these silly bits over the PA, and it's so
annoying to everyone who's trying to get their work done. And Angela, I remember we got a question in our
original breakdown asking if any of it was improvised, but I don't think we dug into the candy bag alts
我先从德克萨斯州奥斯汀的 Melinda D 提出的粉丝问题开始。嗨，女士们。我喜欢迈克尔在对讲机里说些荒谬话的开场戏。这部分有糖果袋里的备选台词吗？谢谢，喜欢这个播客。好的。Melinda，我也很喜欢这个冷开场。吉姆有一句很棒的台词来铺垫，他说，今天早上电话维修工来了，向迈克尔展示了电话有公共广播（PA）功能。然后他就走了。是的。然后迈克尔就在广播里做各种傻事，这让所有试图工作的人都感到非常烦恼。安吉拉，我记得我们在最初的解析中收到过一个问题，问其中是否有即兴发挥，但我认为我们没有深入挖掘糖果袋里的备选台词。
for this. No, lady, we did not. We had read the shooting draft script, so we referenced that.
But Melinda, thanks for writing in because it sent me into the candy bag. There was so much.
much fun stuff there. Are you ready? Here are extra bits they wrote for Michael. Oh my gosh.
They must have had so much fun with this. Right. Okay. So this is all over the intercom thingy,
right? Yes. So it's all voiceover. Michael would have said. Attention Dunder Mifflin shoppers
sale on female secretaries, aisle one. Or Stanley, Toby, Kevin. Those are good fart sounds late.
Thank you.
Please rise for the Pledge of Allegiance.
不，女士，我们没有。我们读的是拍摄剧本，所以我们参考了那个。但 Melinda，谢谢你写信来，因为它让我翻开了糖果袋。里面有很多有趣的东西。准备好了吗？这是他们为迈克尔写的额外片段。天哪。他们一定玩得很开心。对吧。好的。所以这都是关于对讲机的事情，对吧？是的。所以这全是画外音。迈克尔本来说的是：注意了，邓德·米夫林购物者，一号通道的女秘书大甩卖。或者：斯坦利、托比、凯文，那些是很好的放屁声。谢谢。请起立，宣誓效忠。
Get out!
The call is coming from the inside of the house.
And then for the part where Michael is talking on a cell phone and he doesn't realize that the PA is still on, here was an alt for that.
No, the mole hasn't changed in size or shape, but it's moved from my front to my back.
I circled the mole with the marker, but now I can't tell what's marker and what's mole.
That is ridiculous.
I know.
Well, lady, we also got a fan mail flurry for this episode.
滚出去！电话是从房子里面打出来的。然后对于迈克尔在用手机说话，却没意识到广播还开着的那部分，这里有一个备选台词：不，痣的大小和形状没有变，但它从我的前面移到了我的后面。我用记号笔圈出了痣，但现在我分不清什么是记号笔，什么是痣了。那太荒谬了。我知道。好吧，女士，我们这集还收到了大量的粉丝来信。
Was it about how much everyone loves the, it is your birthday party decorating skills?
Close.
It's in that scene.
It actually has to do with our breakdown of the episode.
I guess I thought that Dwight hung up the sad balloons and streamers with clear tape.
and you very passionately said, no, it was masking tape.
And then you pulled out your laptop and you showed me.
And you were correct.
是关于大家有多喜欢“这是你的生日”派对装饰技巧吗？接近了。就在那场戏里。它实际上与我们对这一集的解析有关。我想我当时认为德怀特是用透明胶带挂上了悲伤的气球和彩带，而你非常激动地说，不，那是美纹纸胶带。然后你拿出笔记本电脑给我看。你是对的。
It's masking tape.
But the flurry was because I guess you kept saying mask and tape instead of masking tape.
And Ashley R. Emily L. Christie C. Lindsay P., Steven C. and Stacey R.
all pointed it out and asked, how in the world did I not catch that in the moment?
I say mask and tape.
According to all of these people.
And it's masking.
Masking.
是美纹纸胶带。但之所以会有大量来信，是因为我想你一直说的是“口罩胶带”（mask and tape）而不是“美纹纸胶带”（masking tape）。Ashley R.、Emily L.、Christie C.、Lindsay P.、Steven C. 和 Stacey R. 都指出了这一点，并问，我当时怎么会没听出来？我说了“口罩胶带”。根据所有这些人的说法。其实是“美纹纸”（masking）。美纹纸。
I think it's somewhere in the middle.
All right, all right, you guys, I'll try to say it correctly.
You say it how you want, lady.
Well, lady, you got a letter about this particular episode.
It was inspired by the line that Pam says as her and Michael begin their lecture circuit.
Pam says, yeah, I love being on the road, but I especially love the time and a half pay 24 hours a day for three days because I have a mortgage now.
Gotta bring home the bucks.
Okay.
我觉得介于两者之间。好吧，好吧，你们，我会试着说正确的。你想怎么说就怎么说，女士。好吧，女士，你收到了一封关于这一集的信。它的灵感来自于帕姆和迈克尔开始讲座巡回时帕姆说的那句台词。帕姆说，是的，我喜欢在路上，但我特别喜欢三天 24 小时一倍半的工资，因为我现在有抵押贷款了。得把钱带回家。好的。
Ready for your letter?
Yeah.
It's from Jessica G from Bethel-Mane.
Jessica said, Jenna, and then in parentheses, and of course, Angela, but this question was more for Jenna.
I have listened to your podcast multiple times and listened to your audiobook at least twice now.
crazy to me that when you started your podcast, I was pregnant, and now my baby boy is about to turn six.
Anyways, I was dying to know if Jenna ever watched the show Mad About You.
And if so, do you remember the episode of Season 7, Episode 13, where Paul puts down a deposit on a house for a Valentine's Day gift and Jamie clearly is not impressed?
准备好读你的信了吗？是的。来自伯特利缅因州的 Jessica G。Jessica 说，珍娜，然后括号里写着，当然还有安吉拉，但这个问题主要是给珍娜的。我已经听过你们的播客好几次了，也听过你们的有声书至少两次了。我开始听你们播客时怀孕了，现在我的小男孩快六岁了，这对我来说太疯狂了。无论如何，我非常想知道珍娜是否看过《为你疯狂》（Mad About You）这部剧。如果是的话，你还记得第七季第 13 集吗？保罗为情人节礼物付了房子的定金，而杰米显然并不领情。
Made me think of your opinion about Jim buying a house for Pam.
And when I rewatch the episode of Matt About You, all I could think about was, ooh, Jenna would not like this episode.
Love you, gals.
And thank you for getting me through my pregnancy, COVID, re-listing when my anxiety took over.
You guys were a wonderful thing to calm my brain.
Take care.
And thank you for all you do.
Oh, my gosh, Jessica.
这让我想到了你对吉姆为帕姆买房子的看法。当我重温《为你疯狂》那一集时，我脑子里想的都是，噢，珍娜肯定不会喜欢这一集。爱你们，姑娘们。谢谢你们陪我度过怀孕期、新冠疫情，以及当我焦虑时重温这些节目。你们是让我大脑平静的美好事物。保重，谢谢你们所做的一切。天哪，Jessica。
I would probably have the same reaction if I was watching that episode of Matt About You.
I did not remember.
I mean, I used to watch Mad About You, but that is so similar.
Like he bought a house for Valentine's Day?
Yeah. Like, I just think that you shouldn't surprise someone with such a large purchase.
It's really a simple sort of like code of like relationship. Maybe, just maybe. If that's how big the price tag is, include me in the conversation.
I'm going to throw something else at you. Do you ever see like all the super richy rich people, they'll like buy their loved one a car as a gift?
like a $200,000 Bentley or something. That's crazy. Don't do that either. What if I don't like how it drives?
如果我在看那一集《为你疯狂》，我可能会有同样的反应。我不记得了。我的意思是，我以前看过《为你疯狂》，但这太相似了。就像他为了情人节买了一套房子？是的。我的意思是，我不认为你应该用如此大的购买行为给某人惊喜。这真的是一种简单的关系准则。也许，只是也许。如果价格标签这么大，请把我纳入讨论范围。我要向你抛出另一件事。你有没有见过那些超级有钱人，他们会给爱人买一辆车作为礼物？比如 20 万美元的宾利什么的。那太疯狂了。也不要那样做。如果我不喜欢它的驾驶感怎么办？
If I haven't test driven something, if I haven't looked at the house and considered the financial impact on our family, don't buy me shit like that. I don't want that.
I'm very short, so I have to sit in it. Can I reach the buttons? You know what I'm saying?
Listen to me. I mean, I'm like, don't buy me a Bentley. Don't buy me a Jaguar. But all.
Also don't. I mean it. Like, I don't want it. I don't want that item. I don't want to be saddled with it. I don't want to drive it. Do I want to park a $200,000 car? You know what? There's probably special parking for that. There's probably a richy, rich world I don't know about. I'm going to stop you right there. You're talking like yacht people talk and that's not us. You know, bless you if you want all that stuff. That's your business. It's none of my business. But I want you to know this. Look at me right now. Are you looking at me?
Yeah. No one is ever going to buy you a Bentley.
No one's ever going to buy me belly. I don't have to worry. You don't have to worry about it.
Okay. What if I get like a superhero movie? It's a huge franchise. No. I'm kicking ass and it makes so much money at the box office that the studio wants to send me a gift. I'm going to tell him to call me. Tell him to call me.
Okay. Don't send her a Bentley. You'll tell them.
如果我没有试驾过，如果我没有看过房子并考虑过对我们家庭的财务影响，别给我买那种东西。我不想要。我很矮，所以我得坐在里面。我能碰到按钮吗？你知道我在说什么吗？听我说。我的意思是，我像是在说，别给我买宾利。别给我买捷豹。但也别。我是认真的。我不想要它。我不想要那个东西。我不想被它拖累。我不想开它。我想停一辆 20 万美元的车吗？你知道吗？那可能有特殊的停车位。可能有一个我不知道的富人世界。我要在这里打断你。你说话像游艇上的人，那不是我们。你知道，如果你想要所有那些东西，祝福你。那是你的事。不关我的事。但我希望你知道这一点。看着我。你在看我吗？是的。没有人会给你买宾利。没有人会给我买宾利。我不必担心。你不必担心。好的。如果我拍了一部超级英雄电影呢？这是一个巨大的系列。不。我表现出色，票房赚了很多钱，制片厂想送我一份礼物。我会告诉他们给我打电话。告诉他们给我打电话。好的。别送她宾利。你会告诉他们的。
Yeah.
Thank you. All right, thanks to everyone who wrote in. And because I love a deep dive, I want to give a
shout out to a very fun one in this episode. Angela, you had a great deep dive on the Mounds Candy Bar and
its role in World War II. I still think about it sometimes. It's awesome. It's so cool.
Anyway, all right, everyone. Enjoy your day. And here's our second drink of Lecture Circuit Part 1.
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends.
Now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you.
Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
是的。谢谢。好的，感谢所有写信来的人。因为我喜欢深入挖掘，我想向这一集中一个非常有趣的深挖点致敬。安吉拉，你对 Mounds 糖果棒及其在二战中的作用做了一次很棒的深入挖掘。我有时还会想到它。太棒了。太酷了。总之，好的，大家。祝你们今天愉快。这是我们的《讲座巡回》第一部分第二杯。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。
We're the office ladies.
Angela just turned out the lights in the studio.
Okay, here's the thing.
There's a lot of buttons.
This is what I want from a light switch.
I want one button.
There's four buttons over there, Jenna.
There's more than four.
我们是办公室女士。安吉拉刚刚关掉了演播室的灯。好的，事情是这样的。有很多按钮。这就是我想要的灯开关。我想要一个按钮。那边有四个按钮，珍娜。不止四个。
You guys, it is a complicated light switch.
Thank you.
But we like to listen to our theme song to get in the mood.
So we're listening to it with you.
All during our theme song, Angela is pressing the buttons.
The lights are going up.
They're going down.
They're fading.
你们，这是一个复杂的灯开关。谢谢。但我们喜欢听我们的主题曲来进入状态。所以我们正在和你一起听。在我们的主题曲期间，安吉拉一直在按按钮。灯光亮起。它们熄灭。它们在变暗。
There's track lighting.
Then there's these other kind of lights and ceiling lights.
Then there's four lamps.
We should turn some of the lamps on.
That might help me.
We need the light because our eyes are fading.
Because I can't see, guys.
That's what's happening.
有轨道灯。然后还有其他种类的灯和吸顶灯。然后有四盏灯。我们应该打开一些灯。那可能会帮到我。我们需要光，因为我们的眼睛正在变暗。因为我看不见，伙计们。这就是正在发生的事情。
But all right, we're here.
The lights are on, and we are ready.
We are ready for lecture circuit part one.
Season 5, Episode 16, written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Ken Kwapis.
It's an official two-parter.
It is, and I've got a whole fast fact about it.
Oh, look how your face just lit up.
You're so excited.
但好吧，我们在这儿。灯亮了，我们准备好了。我们准备好讲座巡回第一部分了。第五季第 16 集，由敏迪·卡灵编剧，肯·卡皮斯执导。这是一个官方的两集连播。是的，我有一个关于它的完整速记事实。噢，看你的脸亮起来了。你太兴奋了。
I am.
Here is your summary.
Michael, accompanied by Pam, is embarking on a three-day lecture tour of the nearby Dundermifflin branches.
I need to stop you one second.
Yeah.
Three days.
Three days, Pam is going to be on the road with Michael.
我是。这是你的总结。迈克尔在帕姆的陪同下，开始了为期三天的邓德·米夫林附近分公司的讲座巡回。我需要打断你一下。是的。三天。是的。三天，帕姆要和迈克尔在路上。
And she's so cheery about it.
At the beginning.
Well, you know, Michael's branch is outselling all the other branches.
David Wallace is perplexed.
What's that secret sauce?
Please go to the other branches and tell them all about it.
Yeah.
Well, they're going to start in Utica.
而且她一开始很开心。嗯，你知道，迈克尔的分公司销量超过了所有其他分公司。大卫·华莱士很困惑。那秘方是什么？请去其他分公司告诉他们这一切。是的。好吧，他们要从尤蒂卡开始。
This is where they're going to run into Karen, and they are met with a surprise.
Yeah.
But back in Scranton, we reveal that Jim and Dwight are now the co-heads of the party planning committee.
And they forgot Kelly's birthday.
And she is ticked off.
Oh, that is an understatement.
Meanwhile, Andy has a crush on one of Stanley's clients.
Fast fact number one.
这是他们会遇到凯伦的地方，他们会遇到一个惊喜。是的。但在斯克兰顿，我们揭示了吉姆和德怀特现在是派对策划委员会的联合负责人。他们忘记了凯利的生日。她气疯了。噢，那还是轻描淡写。与此同时，安迪对斯坦利的一位客户产生了迷恋。速记事实第一条。
Mm-hmm.
Lecture Circuit is a two-part episode.
It aired two different weeks, and this is our first episode to ever feature a to be continued message, you know, at the end of the episode.
But lecture circuit was not written as two episodes.
It was one script, like your regular 41 pages long.
We shot it in five days.
So why did they make it a two-parter, Jenna?
I will tell you.
嗯哼。《讲座巡回》是一个两集连播的剧集。它在两周内播出，这是我们第一集在剧集结尾出现“未完待续”信息的剧集。但《讲座巡回》并不是作为两集编写的。它是一个剧本，就像你通常 41 页长的那样。我们用了五天时间拍摄。那么为什么他们把它做成两集呢，珍娜？我会告诉你。
I thought you might.
I was trading emails with director Ken Kwapis.
He told me that when they went to assemble it in the...
editing room, there was so much good stuff. His director's cut was 35 minutes long. He showed it to Greg,
and he said, Greg, I can't cut anymore. That's it. It's got to be 35 minutes, Greg. Yeah,
make it supersized. Yeah. Or something. Something. Greg said, I agree. We can't lose any of this.
Let's turn it into two episodes. And Ken said he was thrilled. That's amazing. That's how good it was.
Yeah. Mindy and Ken turned in, that good.
我想你会的。我当时正在和导演肯·卡皮斯互通邮件。他告诉我，当他们去剪辑室组装它时，有太多好东西了。他的导演剪辑版有 35 分钟长。他给格雷格看，他说，格雷格，我不能再剪了。就是这样。必须是 35 分钟，格雷格。是的，把它做成超大号的。是的。或者别的什么。别的什么。格雷格说，我同意。我们不能失去任何这些。让我们把它变成两集。肯说他很激动。太神奇了。这就是它有多好。是的。敏迪和肯交出的，那么好。
of an episode. Well, fastback number two, when they broke up the episode into two episodes,
they did actually need more storylines to fill out each half. So they knew that the lecture
circuit story and the birthday party story would remain in both episodes, but it actually wasn't
enough for two complete episodes. So they had to write two more stories. And what were those?
I will tell you, for this episode, they added the storyline of eight.
Andy wanting to date Stanley's client, Julia.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
的一集。好吧，速记事实第二条，当他们把这一集拆分成两集时，他们确实需要更多的故事情节来填补每一半。所以他们知道讲座巡回的故事和生日派对的故事会保留在两集中，但这实际上不足以支撑两集完整的剧集。所以他们不得不写两个更多的故事。那是什么？我会告诉你，对于这一集，他们增加了安迪想和斯坦利的客户朱莉娅约会的故事线。嗯哼。是的。
That makes sense because in the original script, it's not in there at all.
No.
And then for the second half, which we will get to next week, they wrote a very interesting
storyline for you and your cats.
Oh, yeah.
I have stories, guys.
So let's talk about this storyline with Stanley and his client, Julia, that they added.
The reason that he doesn't meet with his client in the conference.
这说得通，因为在原始剧本中，它根本不在里面。不。然后对于下半部分，我们下周会讲到，他们为你和你的猫写了一个非常有趣的故事线。噢，是的。我有故事，伙计们。所以让我们谈谈他们增加的斯坦利和他的客户朱莉娅的故事线。他不在会议室见客户的原因。
room is because the conference room was busy being a birthday party.
Sure.
It was being decorated.
So they did all of that in the break room.
And also, that way, they could insert it into the episode wherever they wanted and it wouldn't
affect any of the continuity of the other story.
And they could shoot it later because that's what we did.
Yes.
是因为会议室正忙着开生日派对。当然。它正在被装饰。所以他们在休息室做了所有这些。而且，这样他们就可以把它插入到剧集的任何地方，而不会影响其他故事的连续性。而且他们可以稍后拍摄，因为这就是我们所做的。是的。
We shot these two additional storylines a full month later.
Mm-hmm.
That was the crazy thing.
For me, they were like, okay, you have a whole storyline.
It's going to be in lecture circuit.
We're shooting it in three weeks.
Yeah.
What?
我们在整整一个月后拍摄了这两个额外的故事线。嗯哼。那是疯狂的事情。对我来说，他们就像，好的，你有一个完整的故事线。它会在讲座巡回里。我们三周后拍摄。是的。什么？
Because they had to write it.
Yeah.
Should we move on to Fast fact number three?
Well, you sound eager, I think we should.
Well, it's a location breakdown.
You love a location breakdown.
I really do.
I know.
因为他们必须写它。是的。我们应该继续进行速记事实第三条吗？嗯，你听起来很急切，我想我们应该。好吧，这是一个地点解析。你喜欢地点解析。我真的很喜欢。我知道。
I love knowing where we made the stuff happen.
Yeah.
You want to be in the room where it happens.
Hamilton.
Hey.
Room where it happens.
I love that.
I really love that song.
我喜欢知道我们在哪里让事情发生。是的。你想在事情发生的地方。汉密尔顿。嘿。事情发生的地方。我喜欢那个。我真的很喜欢那首歌。
I do too.
We had a fan question from Joe S.
Jenna, did you and Steve film your scenes in the car in a single day or multiple days?
And where did you drive around to film the car scenes?
I'll tell you.
We shot all of the driving scenes for both lecture circuit one and lecture circuit part two on the same one day.
Oh, wow.
So you had a full day in the car.
我也一样。我们有一个来自 Joe S 的粉丝问题。珍娜，你和史蒂夫是在一天还是多天内拍摄车里的戏份的？你们开车去哪里拍摄车里的戏份？我会告诉你。我们把《讲座巡回》第一部分和第二部分的所有驾驶场景都在同一天拍摄了。噢，哇。所以你在车里待了一整天。
Yep, just driving around.
Just driving around.
It was Wednesday, November 5th.
Look at you.
Mm-hmm.
Someone got the call sheet and looked at it.
And that someone is Jenna Fisher.
Yes, thanks to James Carey.
是的，就在周围开车。就在周围开车。那是 11 月 5 日，星期三。看看你。嗯哼。有人拿到了通告单并看了它。而那个人就是珍娜·费舍尔。是的，多亏了詹姆斯·凯里。
So here's where we went.
We made a loop of three streets in North Hollywood, Nordoff, Satakoi, and Plummer.
I recognize Satakoy.
Yeah.
That's also the street that our sound stages were on.
That's the street we drove on every single day.
To get to work.
Yeah.
所以这是我们去的地方。我们在北好莱坞的三条街道上绕了一圈，诺多夫、萨塔科伊和普卢默。我认得萨塔科伊。是的。那也是我们的摄影棚所在的街道。那是我们每天开车的街道。去上班。是的。
I will tell you, I was not actually driving in these scenes.
You weren't?
No.
You did some good faky driving.
Thank you so much.
I was going to ask you if you drove at all.
I did not.
Oh.
我会告诉你，我在这些场景中并没有真正开车。你没有？不。你做了一些很好的假装驾驶。非常感谢。我正要问你是否开车了。我没有。噢。
They had the car loaded onto a rig, and it was being pulled by a precision driver.
Okay.
I'm not much of a precision driver.
I wouldn't describe myself that way at all.
Precision is not the word I would think of to describe my driving.
Jenna, I've ridden with you in a car.
I know.
You know, you're a very safe driver.
他们把车装在了一个装置上，由一名精准驾驶员拉着。好的。我不是什么精准驾驶员。我根本不会那样描述自己。精准不是我会用来描述我驾驶的词。珍娜，我坐过你的车。我知道。你知道，你是一个非常安全的驾驶员。
Mm-hmm.
But you, what are you going to say?
You, I don't know, it's like you grip the wheel with both hands.
I do.
I'm a 10 and 2.
You're a 10 and 2.
And then you just kind of, you look straight ahead.
And sometimes I'm like, you know, you can go around them, Jenna.
嗯哼。但你，你要说什么？你，我不知道，就像你双手紧握方向盘。我确实。我是 10 点和 2 点方向。你是 10 点和 2 点方向。然后你只是，你直视前方。有时我会说，你知道，你可以绕过他们，珍娜。
There's a whole lane that's empty right next to you.
We've been behind Pokey Pokerson for like half an hour.
10 and 2, turn a little bit and go around them.
Can I say something right now?
Mm-hmm.
This driving does actually sound very precise.
Okay.
Well, maybe I am a precision driver and I don't know it.
你旁边有一整条空车道。我们已经在那个慢吞吞的人后面待了半小时了。10 点和 2 点，转一点，绕过他们。我现在能说点什么吗？嗯哼。这种驾驶听起来确实非常精准。好的。好吧，也许我是一个精准驾驶员，而我不知道。
You're a slow precision driver.
You're not going to be taking any courses where you're like zipping around any cones.
You'll get around those.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Are you doing cone courses in your free time?
Yeah.
Is that your hobby?
Do you not know this about me?
你是一个缓慢的精准驾驶员。你不会参加任何那种你在锥桶周围飞驰的课程。你会绕过那些。噢，抱歉。你在业余时间做锥桶课程吗？是的。那是你的爱好吗？你不知道关于我的这一点吗？
I'm a freaking badass.
Like, I do, I actually, by the way, I did pull off the road.
Like, we did all that driving sequence.
I was driving when Dwight runs me off the road.
That was me.
Oh, yeah.
What do you want?
我是一个该死的狠角色。就像，我确实，顺便说一句，我确实把车开出了路面。就像，我们做了所有那些驾驶序列。当德怀特把我逼出路面时，我在开车。那是我。噢，是的。你想要什么？你想要什么？
I want my precision driving trophy.
It's a little gold, like, street cone.
All right.
I'll find one for you and I will get it for you.
Okay.
So anyway, you were not driving, but you shot all in one day.
We shot it all in one day.
And then the next day, we shot everything at the Utica branch. And we started with all of the interior scenes. And we shot at this building in Chatsworth, California. It was on Hordoff Street. And we started very early that day. We started at 5.30 in the morning. That was your call time? Yeah. And the crew call was 630 and the shooting call was 645. What that means is that we had the goal of arriving at 530, rehearsing at 3rd.
我想要我的精准驾驶奖杯。那是一个小金色的，像街道锥桶。好的。我会为你找一个，我会为你拿到的。好的。所以总之，你没有开车，但你都在一天内拍摄了。我们都在一天内拍摄了。然后第二天，我们在尤蒂卡分公司拍摄了一切。我们从所有的室内场景开始。我们在加利福尼亚州查茨沃斯的一栋大楼里拍摄。它在霍多夫街上。那天我们开始得很早。我们早上 5 点 30 分开始。那是你的通告时间？是的。剧组通告是 6 点 30 分，拍摄通告是 6 点 45 分。这意味着我们的目标是 5 点 30 分到达，3 点排练。
6.30, and we had to start shooting by 6.45 a.m. That's the early day. And we did it. All right. So,
before we go to break, lady, I think we should give a little book update. Book update. Office
BFFs is the name of our book that we have been working on for... Oh, good Lord, three years.
Longer than I can imagine. Oh, my goodness. We've been sharing on our Instagram, like our journey as we're
writing this together. And guess what? Well, you might know if you follow us. We finished our manuscript.
We turned in our manuscript. Someone throw some confetti. Please. Your husband, Josh, did throw confetti
when you told him that we had finished it. It was so sweet. But now we are in this really fun
part where we are going through all of our photos. So many photos. And they're so good.
6 点 30 分，我们必须在早上 6 点 45 分开始拍摄。那是很早的一天。我们做到了。好的。所以，在休息之前，女士，我觉得我们应该更新一下书的进度。书的更新。《办公室 BFFs》是我们一直在写的那本书的名字，已经写了……噢，天哪，三年了。比我能想象的还要长。噢，天哪。我们一直在我们的 Instagram 上分享我们一起写书的旅程。你猜怎么着？好吧，如果你关注我们，你可能知道。我们完成了手稿。我们交了手稿。有人扔点五彩纸屑。拜托。你的丈夫乔什在你告诉他我们完成时确实扔了五彩纸屑。太甜了。但现在我们处于这个非常有趣的部分，我们正在整理我们所有的照片。太多的照片了。而且它们太棒了。
Because you guys, the reason we wanted to write this book in the first place was because we did this
clean out of our garages and your shed and my basement. Basically, it's everywhere we stash stuff.
Yeah. And you know what we found out? What did we find? We're big stashers. We did not need to find
that out, lady. I think we knew that. Oh my gosh. But it's true. And we saved everything.
Every scrap of paper, every ticket stub. Here's the other thing, too. Not only do we save everything,
but like our family does.
I have a whole envelope from my cousin Carol of all of these clippings.
Thank you, Carol.
因为你们，我们最初想写这本书的原因是因为我们清理了我们的车库、你的棚子和我的地下室。基本上，这是我们藏东西的每一个地方。是的。你知道我们发现了什么吗？我们发现了什么？我们是超级囤积者。我们不需要发现这一点，女士。我想我们知道。噢，天哪。但这是真的。我们保存了一切。每一张纸屑，每一张票根。还有另一件事。不仅我们保存了一切，我们的家人也一样。我有一个来自我表姐卡罗尔的整个信封，里面装满了这些剪报。谢谢你，卡罗尔。
Well, all of this stuff is going in the book.
I don't know that we can put all of it in the book.
The book would be like 800 pages.
That's true.
Some of this stuff is going in the book, but it's all really fun.
And you guys, I just am so excited for you to get it and to hold it in your hands and to have it.
Me too.
I'm excited to go on our book tour.
好吧，所有这些东西都要放进书里。我不知道我们能不能把所有东西都放进书里。这本书会有 800 页。那是真的。有些东西会放进书里，但这真的很有趣。你们，我只是太兴奋了，想让你们得到它，把它拿在手里，拥有它。我也是。我很兴奋去参加我们的新书巡回。
What?
Lady, you know when your book comes out, you go on a tour and you like sign it and you meet people.
We're going to get to go on like a ladies.
A road trip.
I hadn't even thought that far ahead.
I'm sorry I'm yelling.
I'm so excited.
什么？女士，你知道当你的书出版时，你会去巡回，你会签名，你会见人。我们要去参加像女士们那样的。公路旅行。公路旅行。我甚至没想那么远。抱歉我在大喊。我太兴奋了。
Okay, you know this has been something I've wanted for a long time, which is a BFF road trip.
I know.
It's going to happen.
Like a real deal road trip where we go to multiple cities.
Well, it's happening.
Get ready for it.
Office BFFs with all our hoarded stuff and all of our great stories.
It's coming your way soon.
好的，你知道这是我一直想要的东西，那就是 BFF 公路旅行。我知道。它会发生的。就像真正的公路旅行，我们去多个城市。好吧，它正在发生。准备好迎接它吧。《办公室 BFFs》，带着我们囤积的所有东西和我们所有伟大的故事。它很快就会来到你身边。
Oh my God, I didn't even think about going on tour.
Well, there you go.
There's our book update.
Life update.
Hit the road update.
Look, I'm already excited.
The book is not even done, and I'm like planning our road trip.
Oh, I have my places I like to stop and snack at.
天哪，我甚至没想过要去巡回。好吧，给你。这就是我们的书的更新。生活更新。上路更新。看，我已经很兴奋了。书还没写完，我就已经在计划我们的公路旅行了。噢，我有我喜欢停下来吃零食的地方。
What are they?
Where will I be snacking?
I love a good, like, just greasy burger joint.
For sure.
Right?
Mm-hmm.
Also, I love.
love the Frito chili chips, you know? Oh, really? You're going to eat Frito chili chips around me? Everyone says they stink up the room. It's so stinky lady. I know. I love them. Okay. They're one of my go-to road trip snacks. Okay. Okay. All right. We're going to go to break now and I'm going to just try to convince Angela to eat regular Frito. I love a regular Frito. Oh, especially with some queso. Oh, you know what I love a regular frito with? What? A Frito chili pie. I'm so hungry now. Like in the bag. I know.
它们是什么？我会在哪里吃零食？我喜欢那种，就是油腻的汉堡店。当然。对吧？嗯哼。另外，我喜欢。喜欢 Frito 辣椒片，你知道吗？噢，真的吗？你要在我身边吃 Frito 辣椒片？每个人都说它们让房间发臭。太臭了，女士。我知道。我喜欢它们。好的。它们是我公路旅行的首选零食之一。好的。好的。好吧，我们要去休息了，我只是要试着说服安吉拉吃普通的 Frito。我喜欢普通的 Frito。噢，特别是配上一些奶酪酱。噢，你知道我喜欢用普通的 Frito 配什么吗？什么？Frito 辣椒派。我现在太饿了。就像在袋子里一样。我知道。
Give it to me.
We'll be back in a second.
One day, you're negotiating with suppliers.
The next, you're installing a shelf in the back room.
Running a business means moving in many directions all the time.
TD's new small business banking accounts are built for how your business moves.
It's how we're making banking more human.
Are you one of those media strategy people clicking through slides, scrolling spreadsheets?
给我。我们一会儿回来。有一天，你在和供应商谈判。第二天，你在后屋安装架子。经营企业意味着一直向多个方向移动。道明银行（TD）新的小企业银行账户是为你的业务运作方式而建立的。这就是我们让银行业务更人性化的方式。你是那些点击幻灯片、滚动电子表格的媒体策略人员之一吗？
Yes?
Good.
This is for you.
Because on Spotify, there's an audience that's different.
Locked in.
loyal, invested.
They're called fans.
Fans don't just listen to music.
是的？很好。这是给你的。因为在 Spotify 上，有一种不同的受众。专注的。忠诚的。投入的。他们被称为粉丝。粉丝不仅仅是听音乐。
They feel seen by it, like it belongs to them.
So when your brand shows up on Spotify, that's who you're talking to.
And you're right next to artists like me, Lizzo.
So, are you ready to talk to fans?
Spotify advertising.
You're among fans.
We are back.
We're in this episode now.
他们感到被音乐所理解，就像它属于他们一样。所以当你的品牌出现在 Spotify 上时，你就是在和这些人对话。而且你就在像我这样的艺术家旁边，Lizzo。那么，你准备好和粉丝对话了吗？Spotify 广告。你在粉丝之中。我们回来了。我们现在在这一集里。
Michael, you guys.
Oh my gosh.
A phone guide came in to fix his phone and showed him the PA system.
You can't show Michael Scott the office PA system.
You definitely cannot.
He is really goofing about now.
Yeah, he pretends to be a plane captain, a ghost.
He forgets the intercom is on while he's talking to his doctor about his mole.
迈克尔，你们。噢，天哪。一个电话维修工进来修理他的电话，并向他展示了公共广播系统。你不能向迈克尔·斯科特展示办公室的公共广播系统。你绝对不能。他现在真的在胡闹。是的，他假装是飞机机长、鬼魂。他在和医生谈论他的痣时，忘记了对讲机还开着。
He calls Toby into the principal's office for waiting his bed.
I think we should hear it.
Can you play the clip?
Yeah.
This is your captain speaking.
The office will be flying at an altitude of two stories.
Look out your left hand window and you will see vance refrigeration.
Boop about my mole again.
他把托比叫到校长办公室，因为他尿床了。我觉得我们应该听听。你能播放那个片段吗？是的。这是你们的机长在说话。办公室将以两层楼的高度飞行。看向你的左手窗户，你会看到万斯制冷。嘘，又在说我的痣了。
Now, I was looking online about sebaceous sips.
I had not been squeezing it.
Because I stick it with a pin.
Ugh.
Don't be blunderson to the principal's office.
No, you have to get home to wash your seat because they're yellow and they're wet with your urine.
My personal favorite part of that is the coughing.
Yes.
现在，我正在网上查看皮脂腺。我没有挤它。因为我用针扎它。呃。别把布伦德森叫到校长办公室。不，你得回家洗你的座位，因为它们是黄色的，而且被你的尿液弄湿了。我个人最喜欢的部分是咳嗽。是的。
I loved listening to him.
cough. It reminded me of the tiramisu coughing fit that he had on the phone with David Wall.
Steve Krill is a master at fake laughing and fake coughing. Yeah. You believe it.
We had a fan question from Virginia S. When Michael is on the PA system, were any of his announcements improvised or were they all in the script? For example, the announcement that Toby has wet his bed is hilarious.
All right. They had several alts. And the one that was actually in the script,
script for Toby, read like this. Toby Flanderson to the principal's office, you are in trouble for sucking.
That's pretty good. That's what was in the script. Well, I read the script while I watched this portion,
and I would say that a lot of it was scripted, but Steve definitely did do improvisations off of what was
我喜欢听他。咳嗽。这让我想起了他在电话里和大卫·华莱士谈话时那种提拉米苏式的咳嗽发作。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是假笑和假咳嗽的大师。是的。你相信它。我们有一个来自弗吉尼亚 S 的粉丝问题。当迈克尔在公共广播系统上时，他的公告是即兴的还是都在剧本里？例如，托比尿床的公告太搞笑了。好的。他们有几个备选。而剧本里实际有的，托比的剧本是这样写的：托比·弗兰德森到校长办公室，你因为吸吮而惹上麻烦了。那还不错。那就是剧本里的内容。好吧，我在看这一部分时读了剧本，我会说其中很多是按剧本来的，但史蒂夫绝对在剧本的基础上做了即兴发挥。
written. And I'm sure Mindy was pitching things to him too on the day. Yes. But I noticed that the line about
Ghost of Christmas Pass. That was scripted, but the coughing bit was not in the script.
Really quickly. I feel like we need to point out something at 27 seconds. What's that?
What's up with Angela's outfit? What is it? It is a poofy, floofy sweater. Oh, yeah.
But it's like poofy, like at the shoulder. That was really in, and I feel like that's coming back.
What? Like the poofy arms. Oh. We went through a real shakes.
Spear Renaissance Fair thing back then.
I'm not here for it.
而且我敢肯定敏迪当天也在向他推销一些东西。是的。但我注意到关于“过去圣诞节的鬼魂”那句台词。那是按剧本来的，但咳嗽的部分不在剧本里。很快。我觉得我们需要指出 27 秒处的一些事情。那是什么？安吉拉的衣服怎么了？那是什么？那是一件蓬松的、毛茸茸的毛衣。噢，是的。但它就像蓬松的，在肩膀处。那真的很流行，我觉得它又要回来了。什么？就像蓬松的袖子。噢。我们当时经历了一场真正的莎士比亚文艺复兴博览会。我不是为了那个。
It's coming back, lady.
Great.
You know what I found in my closet?
How do I describe this?
I found a ribbon on a hanger.
Okay.
And then clipped to the ribbon were various flowers that I could put in my hair or on my lapel.
You could adorn your outfit.
它又要回来了，女士。太棒了。你知道我在衣柜里发现了什么吗？我怎么描述这个？我在衣架上发现了一条丝带。好的。然后夹在丝带上的是各种花，我可以戴在头发上或翻领上。你可以装饰你的衣服。
Like one of the flowers was like a fabric flower that you would clip on your blue.
laser. Oh, yeah. Was that in for a while? Why do I have seven flowers to clip to myself?
I don't know. It feels very much like a pretty and pink, kind of like a Molly Ringwald, put the
flower on her hat. Yeah, it brought back no memories when I looked at it. Two of the flowers were like
Hawaiian flowers. I clearly bought them to clip in my hair while on a trip to Hawaii. But the rest were more
casual, more every day. But I'm going to clip one on my blazer lapel when we do our book tour.
All right? I'm planting that seed now. I can't wait. It's going to make me real happy. What I won't
have on our book tour is a poofy sleeve sweater because at my age, I don't need any extra poofs.
就像其中一朵花是一朵布花，你会把它夹在你的蓝色上。西装外套。噢，是的。那流行了一段时间吗？为什么我有七朵花可以夹在自己身上？我不知道。这感觉非常像《粉红佳人》，有点像莫莉·林沃德，把花戴在她的帽子上。是的，当我看着它时，它没有带回任何记忆。其中两朵花是夏威夷花。我显然是在去夏威夷旅行时买来夹在头发上的。但其余的更休闲，更日常。但我会在我们新书巡回时把其中一朵夹在我的西装翻领上。好的吗？我现在就在种下那颗种子。我等不及了。这会让我非常高兴。我在我们的新书巡回上不会有蓬松袖子的毛衣，因为在我这个年纪，我不需要任何额外的蓬松。
You know what? I'm going to say you will wear that on our book tour. No. Don't say that.
Poofy sweater thing and flower lapel. Who are we on this book tour?
I don't know. We're interesting people.
Well, we'll see.
Not trust well, but interesting.
All right. Let's get started.
This episode opens with Michael exiting a motel room.
He knocks on the neighboring door and out comes Pam.
你知道吗？我会说你会穿那个参加我们的新书巡回。不。别那样说。蓬松毛衣和花朵翻领。我们在这次新书巡回上是谁？我不知道。我们是有趣的人。好吧，我们会看到的。不是信任，但很有趣。好的。让我们开始吧。这一集以迈克尔走出汽车旅馆房间开始。他敲了隔壁的门，帕姆出来了。
Yes. And in the shooting draft of our script, it says Michael knocks on Pam's door.
They say good morning. That's it.
They don't even have dialogue written out for you guys.
you just sort of greet each other.
This is not in the script.
When Michael Knox says, hello, good morning.
Pam says, good morning.
And then Michael says, you ready?
是的。在我们剧本的拍摄草稿中，它说迈克尔敲了帕姆的门。他们说早上好。就是这样。他们甚至没有为你们写出对话。你们只是互相问候。这不在剧本里。当迈克尔敲门说，你好，早上好。帕姆说，早上好。然后迈克尔说，你准备好了吗？
And we're off like a herd of turtles.
That is not in the script.
I think Steve improvised that.
I will tell you, I absolutely loved doing this episode because I got Steve all to myself.
I bet.
Just scene after scene of me and Steve.
And I loved it.
Some of my favorite times in the office were when I just got to have days with Steve,
然后我们就像一群乌龟一样出发了。那不在剧本里。我想史蒂夫即兴发挥了。我会告诉你，我绝对喜欢拍摄这一集，因为我让史蒂夫一个人陪我。我敢打赌。我和史蒂夫一场接一场的戏。我喜欢它。我在办公室里最喜欢的一些时光就是我能和史蒂夫待在一起的日子，
me and Steve.
I know.
They were brief
and few and far between
because, you know,
Angela Martin hated him,
but those were always
such a delight.
我和史蒂夫。我知道。它们很短暂，而且很少见，因为，你知道，安吉拉·马丁讨厌他，但那些总是那么令人愉快。
Well, I love this scene
of me putting the luggage
into the back of the car.
I did too.
I'm sorry.
I thought I did.
I'm going to toot my own horn.
I thought my heavy luggage
好吧，我喜欢我把行李放进车后备箱的那场戏。我也喜欢。抱歉。我想我做到了。我要吹嘘一下。我觉得我的重行李
acting was superb.
It was so great
that I wrote a question for you.
Here's my fan question.
Okay.
What was in the bag?
It looked really heavy.
There was almost nothing
表演非常精湛。太棒了，以至于我为你写了一个问题。这是我的粉丝问题。好的。包里装的是什么？看起来很重。那个包里几乎什么都没有。
in that bag.
That was,
All me.
Thank you.
I mean, I couldn't be prouder of that.
You know what?
I want a Cone Award for my precision driving.
I'm going to get you a little tiny suitcase.
那是，全靠我。谢谢。我的意思是，我不能为此感到更自豪了。你知道吗？我想要一个精准驾驶的锥桶奖。我要给你一个小小的手提箱。
Thank you.
That says great prop work.
Prop work award.
I don't know if you noticed, but we got a lot of mail about this car.
Adele M wrote in and said,
whose Maroon Ford is Pam driving?
I thought she had a Yaris and Michael had a PT
cruiser. What is this car? Exactly. Is it a rental car? Listen to this. What? This is a gem from Randy Cordray. He said in an early
谢谢。上面写着伟大的道具工作。道具工作奖。我不知道你有没有注意到，但我们收到了很多关于这辆车的邮件。Adele M 写信说，帕姆开的是谁的栗色福特？我以为她有一辆雅力士，迈克尔有一辆 PT 巡洋舰。这是什么车？到底是什么？是租来的车吗？听这个。什么？这是来自兰迪·科德雷的一块宝石。他说在这一集的早期
concept meeting for this episode, it was discussed that Michael would need extra trunk space for all of his
props and his trunk and all that stuff and that it just wouldn't fit in his PT Cruiser. So they said that they
thought it would be funny if Michael had to ask the company to provide him with a Lincoln Town car.
that Pam would drive him around in.
But corporate would only approve a cheaper Crown Victoria.
So this was always intended to be like a scripted moment where we would explain this.
But in the end, it never made the shooting draft.
So it comes off a bit confusing, but this was like a whole joke.
概念会议中，讨论过迈克尔需要额外的后备箱空间来放他所有的道具和他的后备箱以及所有那些东西，而且它根本装不进他的 PT 巡洋舰。所以他们说，如果迈克尔不得不要求公司为他提供一辆林肯城市车，那会很有趣。帕姆会开车带他到处走。但公司只会批准一辆更便宜的皇冠维多利亚。所以这总是被打算作为一个剧本时刻，我们会解释这一点。但最终，它从未进入拍摄草稿。所以它看起来有点令人困惑，但这就像一个完整的笑话。
I love it because Michael thinks he's carrot top, right?
So he's got to have all of his props and his trunks of crazy gadgets and things.
I mean, I'm surprised you didn't dress in a costume.
I was, too.
But yet he gives Pam, like, some sass about her outfit and says, don't you know what a magician's assistant looks like?
I googled magician's assistant costume.
There's a lot of fishnet.
There's some short shorts.
我喜欢它，因为迈克尔认为他是胡萝卜顶（Carrot Top），对吧？所以他必须拥有他所有的道具和他的疯狂小玩意儿的后备箱。我的意思是，我很惊讶你没有穿上戏服。我也是。但他确实对帕姆的衣服发表了一些评论，并说，你不知道魔术师助手看起来像什么吗？我谷歌了魔术师助手戏服。有很多渔网袜。有一些短裤。
There's a boostier.
There's a top hat.
Yeah.
Sometimes a skirt.
It's a very sexy-looking outfit.
Yeah.
Well, Pam wore her tan cardigan.
It's new.
有一个胸衣。有一顶大礼帽。是的。有时是一条裙子。那是一套看起来非常性感的衣服。是的。好吧，帕姆穿了她的棕褐色开衫。它是新的。
I had such a hard time getting through that line because, of course, we knew that line was going to be in the script.
So when we picked my outfit for this episode, we thought it was very funny that her new cardigan was like beige.
Was beige.
I have another amazing tidbit about this car before we get on the road.
The toboggan?
Yeah.
That's on top of the car?
All right.
我很难读完那句台词，因为当然，我们知道那句台词会出现在剧本里。所以当我们为这一集挑选我的衣服时，我们认为她的新开衫是米色的非常有趣。是米色的。在我们要上路之前，关于这辆车我还有另一个惊人的花絮。雪橇？是的。在车顶上？好的。
The reason that's there is because there was a scene.
that was written as a tag for this episode.
And the scene was going to be Michael and Pam going down a snowy hill on that toboggan.
Why didn't that happen?
I need to see that.
Yes.
Well, we'd have to go somewhere with snow.
Randy said they went out to scout a snowy mountain.
它在那里是因为有一个场景。被写成这一集的标签。场景是迈克尔和帕姆坐着那个雪橇下雪山。为什么那没有发生？我需要看到那个。是的。好吧，我们得去有雪的地方。兰迪说他们出去侦察一座雪山。
And the photos that they came back with, it just didn't look great.
There just wasn't a lot of snow happening at the time.
that we were shooting this episode, we couldn't go all the way to mammoth, which is five hours away, right?
We had to find some place that was relatively close, and there just was no snow, so we never shot it.
But there were two options. One was that Michael was going to be going down the hill on the toboggan,
and Pam was just going to be kind of like standing there.
Right. And the other version is that Pam and Michael are sledding down together, but midway down the
Pamp falls off and rolls to the bottom.
他们带回来的照片，看起来不太好。我们拍摄这一集时，雪并不多。我们不能一直去猛犸象山，那有五个小时的路程，对吧？我们必须找到一个相对近的地方，但根本没有雪，所以我们从未拍摄它。但有两个选择。一个是迈克尔要坐着雪橇下山，而帕姆只是站在那里。对。另一个版本是帕姆和迈克尔一起滑雪下山，但在中途帕姆摔倒并滚到了底部。
And Michael says, again!
Well, maybe I'm glad you didn't have to do that, Jenna Fisher.
No, I so wish I could have gone sledding with Steve.
I so wish.
That would have been a blast.
Back at Dundra Mifflin, Kelly arrives to work, and she is really upset.
Yeah.
I would like to note at four minutes, 10 seconds, there is a big door slam.
迈克尔说，再来一次！好吧，也许我很高兴你不需要那样做，珍娜·费舍尔。不，我真希望我能和史蒂夫一起去滑雪。我真希望。那会是一次爆炸。回到邓德·米夫林，凯利到达工作岗位，她真的很心烦。是的。我想指出在 4 分 10 秒处，有一个巨大的关门声。
Guys, that front door did not slam.
No.
It did not.
In fact, it had that little suspension thing, you know, that suspension bracket.
So it just would shut like, he.
So that was added in post.
They had to make it a silent door because a lot of times people would have to enter,
and we'd be in the middle of a scene, and then you would have heard kachunk.
伙计们，那扇前门并没有砰地关上。没有。确实没有。事实上，它有一个小缓冲装置，你知道的，就是那个缓冲支架。所以它关上的时候就像，嘿。所以那是后期加进去的。他们必须把它做成一扇静音门，因为很多时候人们需要进来，而我们正在拍戏，然后你就会听到“砰”的一声。
Right.
So it was a he does not slam.
But they needed to really sell how Mad Kelly was.
So they put it in.
Finky slam.
Well, Mindy says screw you to Jim and Dwight.
She storms off and then Phyllis explains that Kelly is upset because they forgot her birthday yesterday.
没错。所以它并没有砰地关上。对。但他们真的需要表现出凯利有多生气。所以他们加了进去。芬奇式的砰的一声。好吧，明迪对吉姆和德怀特说了句“去你的”。她冲了出去，然后菲利斯解释说凯利很心烦，因为他们昨天忘了她的生日。
Yeah.
We got a piece of mail.
Okay.
From Zoe S.
Here's what Zoe has to say.
In this episode, it's the day after Kelly's birthday.
Jim and Dwight forgot.
Phyllis knew it was Kelly's birthday yesterday.
是的。我们收到了一封邮件。好的。来自佐伊·S。这是佐伊要说的。在这一集中，是凯利生日的第二天。吉姆和德怀特忘了。菲利斯知道昨天是凯利的生日。
But Kelly says nobody wished her.
a happy birthday. Zoe would like to know, why didn't Phyllis wish Kelly a happy birthday if she knew?
I mean, it's one thing that Phyllis wants to make Jim and Dwight look bad, but Phyllis showed some real
sass to Kelly on her birthday. Thank you, Zoe. This is what Angela Martin had to deal with, day in and
day out, the secret Phyllis sass that people don't see. They just see, oh, nice, Phyllis,
but there's a deep current of deep dark secret Phyllis sound.
Mm-hmm.
Passive-aggressive, Phyllis Sass.
但凯利说没有人祝她生日快乐。佐伊想知道，如果菲利斯知道，为什么她不祝凯利生日快乐呢？我的意思是，菲利斯想让吉姆和德怀特看起来很糟糕是一回事，但菲利斯在凯利生日那天对她表现得非常刻薄。谢谢你，佐伊。这就是安吉拉·马丁每天都要面对的事情，人们看不到的菲利斯那种暗地里的刻薄。他们只看到，哦，善良的菲利斯，但菲利斯内心深处有一种深沉的、黑暗的秘密。嗯哼。被动攻击型的菲利斯式刻薄。
This leads us into a talking head that I know these two boys loved filming.
Well, they couldn't get through it.
Mm-hmm.
They couldn't get through this whole episode.
I'm going to be bringing up some bloopers in a minute.
It started with the side-by-side talking head.
And if you read this talking head in the shooting draft, what made it to screen, you can see they were having some fun.
Yeah.
这引出了一个我知道这两个男孩很喜欢拍摄的“谈话头”片段。好吧，他们拍不下去。嗯哼。他们拍不完这一整集。我一会儿会提到一些花絮。它始于并排的谈话头。如果你读过拍摄草稿中的这个谈话头，也就是最终出现在屏幕上的版本，你可以看出他们玩得很开心。是的。
They had some improv around what was written.
The very top, when Jim says,
ahead and Dwight goes, no, you go ahead, you do it. And Jim goes, okay. And Dwight goes, I insist. That was all
improvised. Then they get into the part, you know, where they're telling that Angela was blackmailed
by Phyllis, that's all scripted. But then Dwight goes, what he said was, and he puts a finger towards
Jim's face, and Jim pushes it away and goes, just easy. That's all improv guys. That's just these two
fellas having some fun. I think I could have told you all that because I know these two so well.
Uh-huh. And I know the bits that they would do.
他们在剧本的基础上进行了一些即兴发挥。最开始，当吉姆说“你先请”，德怀特说“不，你先请，你来”，吉姆说“好吧”，德怀特说“我坚持”。这些都是即兴的。然后他们进入了那部分，你知道的，他们说安吉拉被菲利斯勒索了，那是写在剧本里的。但后来德怀特说，“他说的是”，他把手指指向吉姆的脸，吉姆把它推开说，“放轻松”。那全是即兴的，伙计们。那只是这两个家伙在找乐子。我想我本可以告诉你们所有这些，因为我太了解这两个人了。嗯哼。而且我知道他们会做哪些小动作。
do off camera. What about the one at the end? That was all improv too. That whole like, that's on my
side. And then Jim's like, so this was fun. Yes. That's just them playing around. Yeah, that's their
chemistry. Well, after that talking head, we have a Kelly talking head where she explains that
yesterday was her birthday. Everybody forgot. We see that she got all dressed up. There wasn't a party.
This one minute is full of some amazing background.
Oh, let's hear them. The first one is a fan catch from Ryan W. When they show Kelly all dressed up for
her birthday during her talking head, in the background on Dwight's desk, you can see his
bobblehead from Angela. It's back on the desk. I looked at it. Yes, at five minutes, 10 seconds,
在镜头外做。那最后那个呢？那也是即兴的。整段像“那是我的地盘”。然后吉姆说，“所以这很有趣”。是的。那只是他们在玩闹。是的，这就是他们的化学反应。好吧，在那段谈话头之后，我们有一个凯利的谈话头，她解释说昨天是她的生日。每个人都忘了。我们看到她打扮得漂漂亮亮的。没有派对。这一分钟充满了令人惊叹的背景细节。哦，让我们听听。第一个是来自瑞安·W的粉丝发现。当他们展示凯利为生日精心打扮时，在德怀特的办公桌背景里，你可以看到安吉拉送给他的摇头娃娃。它又回到了桌子上。我看了。是的，在5分10秒处，
bobblehead. But also, this is the one I noticed. Creed is milling around in Michael's office.
What? Yeah. He's just milling around in there. What the heck? What's he doing in there? I don't know.
I don't either. Those are my background catches. Those are good catches. Jenna, we all know that Ryan had his list. Remember when he came back? He was mad at everyone. He kept writing down names.
Mm-hmm. Did you know that Angela Martin also has her list? No. She calls it her enemy list.
She's not subtle.
And it all comes up in a scene that was deleted between Jim Dwight and Angela.
She's turning over her party planning committee box of items.
Okay.
摇头娃娃。但还有这个，我注意到了。克里德在迈克尔的办公室里闲逛。什么？是的。他就在那儿闲逛。搞什么鬼？他在那儿干什么？我不知道。我也不知道。这些是我的背景发现。这些发现很棒。珍娜，我们都知道瑞安有他的名单。还记得他回来的时候吗？他生所有人的气。他一直在写名字。嗯哼。你知道安吉拉·马丁也有她的名单吗？不知道。她称之为她的敌人名单。她一点也不含蓄。这一切都出现在吉姆、德怀特和安吉拉之间被删减的一个场景中。她正在移交她的派对策划委员会的物品盒。好的。
Here it is.
I reprinted my vendor's list for parties.
It's a list of birthdays, half birthdays, minutes from past parties, and an enemy's list.
You're going to need it.
If there's some cat stuff mixed in here, I'd appreciate you returning it to me.
Of course.
I wish you two the best of luck.
Thank you.
在这儿。我重新打印了我的派对供应商名单。这是一份生日、半生日、过去派对的会议记录和敌人名单。你们会需要的。如果里面混进了一些猫的东西，我希望你能还给我。当然。祝你们俩好运。谢谢。
Angela, Dwight and I would like to say that we'd be honored
if you would stay on as a member of the committee.
And we think you could even run it
and take care of everything and we would not get in your way.
Well, that is a great idea.
Nice try.
It's your problem now.
I want to say I spit out my coffee
安吉拉，德怀特和我想说，如果你能继续担任委员会成员，我们将不胜荣幸。我们认为你甚至可以管理它，处理一切事务，我们不会妨碍你。好吧，那是个好主意。想得美。现在是你们的问题了。我想说我把咖啡喷出来了
when you explained that you had minutes for the parties.
She's documenting everything that happens at these parties.
And she has an enemies list.
Wow.
Oh.
I mean, those are scenes I would have loved to see.
Toboggan scene?
Yeah.
当你解释说你有派对的会议记录时。她在记录这些派对上发生的一切。而且她有一个敌人名单。哇。哦。我的意思是，那些是我很想看到的场景。平底雪橇场景？是的。
I would love someone to read the minutes of a party.
Yeah.
I agree.
Well, back in the car, Pam wants to turn on the radio, but Michael needs silence.
Or Sam Kinnison in order to prepare, one of those two.
Sam Kinnison, comedian that yelled.
His whole stand-up routine was yelling.
Yes.
我很想有人读读派对的会议记录。是的。我同意。好吧，回到车里，帕姆想打开收音机，但迈克尔需要安静。或者萨姆·金尼森，为了准备，二选一。萨姆·金尼森，那个大喊大叫的喜剧演员。他的整个单口相声表演都在大喊大叫。是的。
He needs one of those two things.
But that's okay. Pam's just going to sing to herself. But then Michael asked Pam if she's nervous about seeing Karen today. He says, is that why you wore makeup today? And Pam's like, what? What? No. I loved that line. I don't know why.
Oh, because it's just one of those statements that completely rattles you. And also because I have so done that. I have so juzzed up a little extra.
And if someone points it out, then you get embarrassed.
Yes. Yeah. Oh, that was such good writing.
So now we start that storyline that Jenna mentioned, that we added to fill out the script,
Stanley is going to escort in Julia, his client.
And I want you to notice. They did not use the front door.
他需要这两者之一。但没关系。帕姆只是自己唱歌。但后来迈克尔问帕姆今天见到凯伦是否紧张。他说，这就是你今天化妆的原因吗？帕姆说，什么？什么？没有。我喜欢那句台词。我不知道为什么。哦，因为它只是那种完全让你心慌意乱的陈述之一。而且因为我也做过那样的事。我确实稍微打扮了一下。如果有人指出来，你就会感到尴尬。是的。是的。哦，那真是太棒的剧本了。所以现在我们开始珍娜提到的那个故事情节，我们为了充实剧本而添加的，斯坦利将护送他的客户朱莉娅进来。我希望你们注意。他们没有走前门。
No, whoever comes in this way, no one.
And the reason they did that was so that they would not have to pass by the conference room
because they didn't know where they were going to put this entrance.
And they just didn't want it to mess up whatever Dwight and Jim might have done or not done
into the conference room yet.
Yes.
So they strategically positioned the camera.
So you see them coming in by that door, by the file cabinet.
不，没有人走这边进来，没有人。他们这样做的原因是这样他们就不必经过会议室，因为他们不知道要把这个入口放在哪里。他们只是不想让它搞乱德怀特和吉姆可能已经在会议室里做过或没做过的事情。是的。所以他们战略性地放置了摄像机。所以你看到他们从那个门，也就是文件柜旁边的门进来。
Yeah.
The only other time we've seen that door was during the fire drill.
Basically.
And I have to tell you, in my mind, I have no idea where that goes.
Where does that go?
We don't know.
是的。我们唯一一次看到那扇门是在消防演习期间。是的。基本上。我必须告诉你，在我脑海里，我不知道那扇门通向哪里。那通向哪儿？我们不知道。我们不知道。
I know where the front door goes.
Yeah.
There's also that door by the break room.
Right.
Where does that go?
Well, we think it goes to the parking lot because Michael and Dwight chased each other,
remember?
Oh, yeah.
我知道前门通向哪儿。是的。休息室旁边还有一扇门。对。那通向哪儿？嗯，我们认为它通向停车场，因为迈克尔和德怀特互相追逐，记得吗？哦，是的。
Like in Prince Family Paper?
I can't put it together in my head.
I can't.
Because obviously those doors went literally nowhere.
They went to snacks backstage is where they went.
But yes, they enter that way so we could place this new storyline anywhere we wanted.
Yes.
Andy notices Julia.
就像在《普林斯家族纸业》里那样？我在脑子里拼凑不出来。我拼凑不出来。因为显然那些门实际上哪儿也不通。它们通向后台的零食区。但是的，他们从那边进来，这样我们就可以把这个新故事情节放在我们想要的任何地方。是的。安迪注意到了朱莉娅。
He is immediately smitten.
Does anybody fall in love at first sight more than Andy?
No, Andy is so...
Maybe Michael.
This might be what they have in common.
They fall in love instantly.
I mean, Michael fell in love with a chair model.
他立刻被迷住了。有人比安迪更容易一见钟情吗？没有，安迪太……也许是迈克尔。也许是迈克尔。这可能是他们的共同点。他们瞬间坠入爱河。我的意思是，迈克尔爱上了一个椅子模特。
Do you know what I'm saying?
You're right.
I'm sorry.
It's definitely Michael, yes.
And Phyllis immediately is like, she's out of your league.
Well, Andy doesn't care that she's out of his league.
He is going to go for it.
He has such a great talking head.
你知道我在说什么吗？你是对的。对不起。绝对是迈克尔，是的。菲利斯立刻说，她配不上你。好吧，安迪不在乎她是否配不上他。他要主动出击。他有一个很棒的谈话头。
It was like so well written when he's like, I'm single now and there's an epic showdown
between the nard dog and crippling despair.
My gosh.
I know.
Well, Jim and Dwight are also going to try an apology.
They want to make it up to her.
And she does this great passive-aggressive thing that we know she doesn't mean where she says,
you know what, all I want is for this to never happen to another person.
写得太好了，他说，“我现在单身，纳德狗和令人瘫痪的绝望之间有一场史诗般的对决”。天哪。我知道。好吧，吉姆和德怀特也要尝试道歉。他们想补偿她。她做了那个我们知道她不是真心的、很棒的被动攻击行为，她说，你知道吗，我只希望这种事永远不要发生在另一个人身上。
Oh, I know.
That's what I want.
Well, they barely got through this scene.
I don't know how they have a usable take.
And then they continue breaking throughout the whole rest of this script.
We got to hear some of these bloopers.
We just wanted to say we're very sorry.
哦，我知道。这就是我想要的。哦，我知道。好吧，他们几乎没能拍完这个场景。我不知道他们怎么会有可用的镜头。然后他们在剩下的剧本里一直在笑场。我们得听听这些花絮。我们只是想说我们非常抱歉。
Screw you guys. You're dead to me.
If you say screw you one more time...
Screw you, Beat Farmer.
Whoa. Okay, guys.
I did the face you like.
If you say screw you one more time...
Oh, guys.
Stop doing that.
去你的，伙计们。你们在我这儿死定了。如果你再说一次“去你的”……去你的，甜菜农夫。哇。好吧，伙计们。我做了你喜欢的那个表情。如果你再说一次“去你的”……哦，伙计们。别再那样做了。
It makes no sense.
If you say screw you one more time...
Hey, guys, just cool it.
You knew.
You knew that one was dead.
Basically...
The dynamics of...
All right.
这毫无意义。如果你再说一次“去你的”……嘿，伙计们，冷静点。你知道的。你知道那个已经没戏了。基本上……动态……好吧。
Within the workplace.
There's always a theme, idiot.
Okay, here's what I have to say.
I can tell from listening to John Laugh that he's crying and he is bent over.
Yes.
He's like in full flop.
Yeah, he has lost it.
One of the hardest times I ever laughed was doing a scene with Mindy and Rain,
在工作场所。总有一个主题，白痴。好吧，这就是我要说的。我听约翰的笑声就能听出来他在哭，而且他弯着腰。是的。他完全崩溃了。我笑得最厉害的一次是和明迪还有雷恩拍戏的时候，
because when you put Mindy and Rain together, nobody is in control.
There's no, the two of them are a mess.
They're the hardest people to do scenes with.
They laugh the most.
And when we get to this episode, I'll show you.
I hope they have a blooper of it, but it reminded me of that.
Well, at the end of the scene, she does say that she would like an ice cream cake.
Were you burping, as you said, ice cream?
因为当你把明迪和雷恩放在一起时，没人能控制住。没有，他们两个是一团糟。他们是最难一起拍戏的人。他们笑得最多。当我们拍到这一集时，我会给你们看。我希望他们有花絮，但这让我想起了那次。好吧，在场景结束时，她说她想要一个冰淇淋蛋糕。你说“冰淇淋”的时候是在打嗝吗？
Or did you have a gurgle?
No.
What just happened?
I don't know.
You did this.
It's cream cake.
I don't know.
I didn't burp.
还是你喉咙里有咕噜声？没有。刚才发生了什么？我不知道。你做了这个。是奶油蛋糕。我不知道。我没打嗝。
I know.
Listen, listen, you already outed me for, like, eating off my shirt.
But I don't also like belch, okay?
It wasn't a burb.
People are like, Jenna doesn't wash her hands, she eats off her shirt.
I don't need belching as part of my reputation now.
You are the one who shared about the hand washing.
Only at home.
我知道。听着，听着，你已经揭穿我吃衣服上的东西了。但我不会打嗝，好吗？那不是打嗝。人们会说，珍娜不洗手，她吃衣服上的东西。我现在不需要把打嗝作为我名声的一部分。是你分享了关于洗手的事。只在家里。
I know.
But I only don't wash my hands after a tinkle at home.
I always wash my hands after a poop.
I always wash my hands after I tinkle or poop in public.
But somehow I've become the poster child for just never washing hands.
hands. And I don't want that on me, okay? That is not who I am. That's what she said.
Oh. You said I don't want that on me. I couldn't help it. All right, I think people had
forgotten about your hygiene and now you've reminded them all. That's what you think. That's what you
我知道。但我只是在家里小便后不洗手。我大便后总是洗手。我在公共场合小便或大便后总是洗手。但不知何故，我成了从不洗手的海报女郎。我不想那样，好吗？那不是我。这就是她说的。哦。你说我不想那样。我忍不住。好吧，我想人们已经忘记了你的卫生习惯，现在你又提醒了他们。你是这么想的。你是这么
think that they remember everything. All I was going to say is, I didn't think it was a belt.
It sounded like a gurgle. You know how you get a gurgle in your throat? Yeah, sometimes maybe I needed
to take a breath, but I pushed through it. Okay. I pushed through to finish.
my sentence. I'm sorry. I'm so sorry. You know what. Okay, okay. All right. We're going to take a break.
Yeah, I'll get plenty of breaths. You should take some water. I'm going to go wash my hands just to prove that I wash them.
Okay. And then when we come back, we've got to get into this conference room. Oh, it's so good. And these balloons and streamers.
We'll be back. We'll be back.
Are you ready for a birthday party? I am. Is it your birthday? It is your birthday. It is your birthday.
想的，他们记得一切。我只想说，我不认为那是打嗝。听起来像咕噜声。你知道喉咙里怎么会有咕噜声吗？是的，有时候也许我需要喘口气，但我坚持下去了。好的。我坚持完成了我的句子。对不起。我真的很抱歉。你知道吗。好的，好的。好吧。我们要休息一下。是的，我会喘够气的。你应该喝点水。我要去洗手，证明我洗了。好的。然后当我们回来时，我们得进入这个会议室。哦，太棒了。还有这些气球和彩带。我们会回来的。我们会回来的。你准备好参加生日派对了吗？我准备好了。是你的生日吗？是你的生日。是你的生日。
your birthday. Period. Period. All right. We're in the conference room. Dwight has decorated for Kelly's
birthday. It is so pitiful. It is pitiful. John is so funny when he enters the conference room.
The way he holds the half-inflated balloon. Do we need to describe this room, by the way?
Okay. For those of you who haven't seen the episode, I hope you watched it this week with us.
Picture a conference table. It is full of half, not even half. No.
There's like just maybe three breaths into a balloon that are brown.
Gray.
Silver?
你的生日。句号。句号。好吧。我们在会议室。德怀特为凯利的生日做了装饰。太可怜了。太可怜了。约翰进入会议室时太搞笑了。他拿着半充气气球的样子。顺便问一下，我们需要描述这个房间吗？好的。对于那些没看过这一集的人，我希望你们这周和我们一起看了。想象一张会议桌。上面全是半个，甚至不到半个。不。大概只有三口气的气球，是棕色的。灰色的。银色的？
I feel like a little silver is in there.
Some sad, like brown beigey streamers.
Dwight has just sort of clipped off and taped to the ceiling.
With like beige masking tape.
No, it was regular clear tape.
No.
Yeah.
There's mask and tape all over the conference room.
我觉得里面有一点银色。一些悲伤的，像棕色米色的彩带。德怀特只是剪下来贴在天花板上。用那种米色的美纹纸胶带。不，那是普通的透明胶带。不。是的。会议室里到处都是美纹纸胶带。
It is hilarious to me.
No, it's clear tape.
No!
It's not.
Oh, no.
This is one of my favorite things about it because have you ever had, like, that guy that you were friends with in college, wrap a gift for you?
And you're like, what did you use?
Electrical tape?
我觉得这太搞笑了。不，是透明胶带。不！不是。哦，不。这是我最喜欢的事情之一，因为你有没有过那种大学朋友帮你包礼物？然后你会说，你用了什么？电工胶带？
What is this?
Painter's tape?
Right.
You had no clear tape?
Oh, Jenna.
Okay.
I got to bring it up.
Do we have – oh, I need a break – do I have my laptop.
这是什么？美纹纸胶带？对。你没有透明胶带吗？哦，珍娜。好吧。我得提一下。我们有——哦，我需要休息——我有我的笔记本电脑吗。
Ha-ha!
She got her laptop back.
I got my laptop.
Back. Oscar Nunez is Jimmy Stewart. Long running, long running inside joke on the office. Long running inside joke now on office ladies. Oh, I can't wait to show you this shi-looking tape. Thank you. To only make it sadder. Okay, where are you? And I have a time code because you know I'm like that. This whole conference room scene with the sad balloons and the sad streamers, it starts at eight minutes, 30 seconds.
Oh, I love it so much.
A hawk and tape!
Oh my gosh!
Not clear tape.
哈哈！她拿回了她的笔记本电脑。我拿回了我的笔记本电脑。奥斯卡·努涅斯是吉米·斯图尔特。办公室里的长期内部笑话。现在是《办公室》女士们的长期内部笑话。哦，我迫不及待想给你们看这种看起来很烂的胶带。谢谢。只会让它更悲伤。好的，你在哪儿？我有一个时间码，因为你知道我是那样的。整个会议室场景，有悲伤的气球和悲伤的彩带，从8分30秒开始。哦，我太喜欢了。美纹纸胶带！天哪！不是透明胶带。
Please look at the shi-maskin tape.
They use to tape up everything.
It is so sad-looking.
I am delighted at this detail that I did not notice until doing this podcast.
It's one of my favorite things.
I also want to point out at 8 minutes 37 seconds, who do you see over John's shoulder?
Oh, that's you, the whole accounting department.
They had me come out to the copier for this scene and watch it.
请看他们用来粘所有东西的烂美纹纸胶带。看起来太悲伤了。我对这个细节感到非常高兴，直到做这个播客我才注意到。这是我最喜欢的事情之一。我还想指出在8分37秒，你在约翰的肩膀上看到了谁？哦，那是你，整个会计部门。他们让我为这个场景出来到复印机旁看着。
I'm in the background every time it pans to the bullpen.
Okay.
Because they sort of thought that Angela Martin would be keeping tabs.
What are they doing?
How are they planning this party?
What are they up to?
So I watch these two grown men disintegrate into tears of laughter.
I don't know how, again, we got any usable footage.
每次镜头扫到办公区时，我都在背景里。好的。因为他们觉得安吉拉·马丁会盯着看。他们在做什么？他们怎么策划这个派对？他们在搞什么鬼？所以我看着这两个成年男人笑得泪流满面。我不知道我们是怎么又拍到可用镜头的。
They laughed so hard, Jenna.
We had to pause.
And this is what Rain said about it.
Ready?
Yes.
In his book, The Bassoon Keyes.
this is what he wrote. The longest inappropriate laughter was during the episode lecture circuit
when Dwight and Jim are put in charge of the party planning committee and Dwight Heng's tiny brown
他们笑得太厉害了，珍娜。我们不得不暂停。这就是雷恩对此说的。准备好了吗？是的。在他的书《巴松管钥匙》里，他写道：最长的不恰当笑声是在《讲座巡回》那一集，当时德怀特和吉姆负责派对策划委员会，德怀特挂了微小的棕色
and gray balloons and a banner that reads, it is your birthday. Rain goes on to say, John and I literally
could not stop laughing. We laughed until we cried. Production needed to be shut down for a 20-minute
break while we gathered ourselves and then we returned to film the scene. Just the way John
picks up the sad balloon from the conference room table.
I don't know how they spoke after that.
I want to tell you the part I remember them laughing at is Dwight says,
are you trying to hurt my feelings?
And he throws the balloon, but it didn't have enough weight to travel in the air.
和灰色气球，还有一条横幅写着“是你的生日”。雷恩接着说，约翰和我真的无法停止大笑。我们笑到哭。制作组不得不停工20分钟休息，让我们平复心情，然后我们回来拍摄这个场景。就约翰从会议桌上拿起那个悲伤气球的方式。我不知道他们之后是怎么说话的。我想告诉你们我记得他们笑的那部分是德怀特说，“你在试图伤害我的感情吗？”然后他扔了气球，但它没有足够的重量在空中飞行。
And so the balloon with the sad streamer attached just kind of went,
you're like in the air, like, but he was trying to throw it at John and it just wouldn't travel.
You can see, I'm going to show you right now, you can see Rain starting to break, because I think he broke every time. Watch.
What is that? It is your birthday period.
Is this a statement a fact? Not even an exclamation point?
This is more professional. It's not like she discovered a cure for cancer.
I can't believe how bad this looks.
Are you trying to hurt my feelings? Because if so, you are succeeding.
所以带着悲伤彩带的气球只是在空中飘了一下，就像，你就像在空中，但他试图把它扔向约翰，它就是飞不动。你可以看到，我现在就给你们看，你可以看到雷恩开始笑场，因为我觉得他每次都笑场。看。那是什么？是你的生日，句号。这是一个陈述事实吗？甚至连感叹号都没有？这更专业。这又不是她发现了癌症的治疗方法。我不敢相信这看起来有多糟糕。你在试图伤害我的感情吗？因为如果是这样，你成功了。
Fortunately, my feelings regenerate at twice the speed of a normal lands.
Did you see her?
The sad balloon is so good.
Oh, my gosh.
So Dwight is annoyed at Jim's reaction to his decorating.
And so he's like, wait, have you collected the money?
You know, for the cake?
幸运的是，我的感情再生速度是正常人的两倍。你看到她了吗？那个悲伤的气球太棒了。天哪。天哪。所以德怀特对吉姆对他装饰的反应感到恼火。所以他说，等等，你收钱了吗？你知道，为了蛋糕？
Yeah, and Jim is like, I've only collected $6.
And Dwight's like, damn it, Jim, that's what we put in.
This got me thinking.
Oh, no.
We are always wondering, where did we get the money for these parties?
There is no way we took a collection for casino night.
Well, no, but for birthday parties, there is clearly a birthday party collection budget.
It's very clear that everyone is supposed to give $3.
是的，吉姆说，我只收了6美元。德怀特说，该死，吉姆，那是我们放进去的。这让我开始思考。哦，不。我们总是想，我们从哪儿弄钱办这些派对？我们不可能为赌场之夜募捐。嗯，不，但对于生日派对，显然有一个生日派对募捐预算。很明显每个人都应该给3美元。
Right?
Okay.
So I counted.
There are 13 people in the office, including Ryan, who's normally in the office, but minus the birthday person that would be 12 people who contribute for each birthday party, $3 per person.
person is $36. The birthday party budget at Dunder Mifflin is $36.
No, I had a gurgle. See? I had a gurgle.
Angela just gurgled. I don't know if you heard it. I had a gurgle. Okay. I don't know what.
No, but you just didn't speak for a second because you were gurgling, so you needed air.
对吧？好的。所以我数了数。办公室里有13个人，包括瑞安，他通常在办公室，但减去过生日的人，那就是12个人为每个生日派对捐款，每人3美元。3美元就是36美元。邓德·米夫林的生日派对预算是36美元。不，我打了个咕噜。看？我打了个咕噜。安吉拉刚才打了个咕噜。我不知道你有没有听到。我打了个咕噜。好的。我不知道什么。不，但你刚才有一秒钟没说话，因为你在打咕噜，所以你需要空气。
Okay, I need to stop drinking fizzy water. This is what it is telling me. Here's the thing.
You're saying how much is the party planning committee budget? The birthday
party budget is $36.
Okay.
I think that's true, except there have been episodes where people go to Angela for petty cash.
And I think Angela's not helping these guys at all.
So maybe like Phyllis, she wants to see them fail.
I feel like there's some petty cash for parties, but she's not going to let them in on that.
好的，我得停止喝气泡水了。这就是它告诉我的。问题是。你说派对策划委员会的预算是多少？生日派对预算是36美元。好的。我认为这是真的，除了有些集里人们去找安吉拉要零用钱。我觉得安吉拉根本没帮这些人。所以也许像菲利斯一样，她想看到他们失败。我觉得派对有一些零用钱，但她不会让他们知道。
That's possible.
I'm just saying.
I was just following this thread, you know.
Yeah.
And here's where it got me.
Did I take the wind out of your sales?
No, I mean, take it or leave it.
birthday party budget is $36 or another theory.
这有可能。我只是说。我只是顺着这个思路，你知道的。是的。这就是我得出的结论。我扫了你的兴吗？不，我的意思是，随你便。生日派对预算是36美元，或者另一个理论。
Whatever you want.
I feel like I'm getting some sass.
I'm not giving you any sass.
I feel a little sass.
I'm just saying I think there is some extra cash.
Can I give you a fan question from Preston G?
Yes.
Preston would like to know who came up with the It Is Your Birthday Period slogan.
随你喜欢。我觉得我得到了一些刻薄的回应。我没给你任何刻薄的回应。我感觉到了一点刻薄。我只是说我认为有一些额外的现金。我可以给你一个来自普雷斯顿·G的粉丝问题吗？是的。普雷斯顿想知道“是你的生日，句号”这个口号是谁想出来的。
Oh, Preston, I want to know that too.
Mindy.
I texted her.
She said it was her.
Genius.
Genius. Genius lady. So, so good. Perfect, too. Perfect that that's what Dwight would write. Perfect.
Should we head over to Utica for a second and check in? Because Pam and Michael have just arrived.
哦，普雷斯顿，我也想知道。明迪。明迪。我给她发了短信。她说那是她。天才。天才。天才女士。太棒了。太完美了。完美的是德怀特会写出那样的话。完美。我们要去尤蒂卡一会儿看看吗？因为帕姆和迈克尔刚到。
They're taking a photo outside of the branch. I guess we're documenting this trip.
Oh, yeah. Are you kidding? I feel like Michael is a scrapbooker.
Yeah. Pam's in charge of all of the bags and taking pictures.
Mm-hmm.
when they arrive, Rolando.
Rolando is back.
Adam Jamal Craig.
So good.
他们在分部外面拍照。我想我们在记录这次旅行。哦，是的。你在开玩笑吗？我觉得迈克尔是个剪贴簿爱好者。是的。帕姆负责所有的包和拍照。嗯哼。当他们到达时，罗兰多。罗兰多回来了。亚当·贾马尔·克雷格。太棒了。
Remember he was in season four in Branch Wars?
Well, he's serving up a bit of sass because he says you're late.
Yeah.
A lot of people pointed out that Michael introduces Pam to Rolando, even though we know from Branch Wars that she knows him.
And the thing that got cut out was that Rolando.
and I were supposed to share like a little look.
Right.
But it didn't make it.
记得他在第四季的《分部战争》里吗？嗯，他表现出了一点刻薄，因为他说你迟到了。是的。很多人指出迈克尔把帕姆介绍给罗兰多，尽管我们从《分部战争》中知道她认识他。被剪掉的部分是罗兰多和我应该分享一个小眼神。对。但没能保留下来。
It's so played for me, though, that Michael would forget who Pam knows and doesn't know.
And he just doesn't really pay attention to what other people do at his own company.
Oh, totally.
This is also when Michael decides to offer Pam a little trick for getting through any nerves she might be feeling about seeing Karen.
Yeah.
She should just picture her naked.
And then Karen enters.
对我来说，迈克尔会忘记帕姆认识谁和不认识谁，这太符合他的性格了。他真的不注意别人在他自己的公司里做什么。哦，完全是。这也是迈克尔决定给帕姆一个小技巧来克服她见到凯伦时可能感到的任何紧张的时候。是的。她应该想象她裸体。是的。然后凯伦进来了。
a very pregnant, Karen.
Yes.
And then Michael, oh my gosh, Michael.
He's like, is it Jim's?
Yeah, and he said, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I'm just trying to calculate in my head,
when's the last time you had sex with Jim?
He said that out loud.
一个非常怀孕的凯伦。是的。然后迈克尔，天哪，迈克尔。他说，是吉姆的吗？是的，他说，对不起，对不起。我只是在脑子里计算，你上次和吉姆发生性关系是什么时候？他大声说了出来。
He said, was it 10 months ago?
To two women that have dated him, are dating him,
so awkward.
We had a fan question from Mickey S.
Was Rashida Jones actually pregnant in this episode?
No, that was Faky Belly.
Faky Belly.
Well, they're going to move into the conference room.
他说，是10个月前吗？对两个和他约会过、正在约会的女人，太尴尬了。我们有一个来自米奇·S的粉丝问题。拉什达·琼斯在这一集里真的怀孕了吗？没有，那是假肚子。假肚子。好吧，他们要搬到会议室去。
Michael's going to start his show, but first he has a phone call.
Yes.
He has a dramatic phone call and then explains to the group that he just learned his father died.
Yeah.
But then he says, I'm just kidding.
But you bought it, you bought it, and you can't return it, or can you?
He got their attention.
What does it have to do with cell?
迈克尔要开始他的表演，但首先他有一个电话。是的。他有一个戏剧性的电话，然后向大家解释他刚得知他父亲去世了。是的。但后来他说，我只是开个玩笑。但你们信了，你们信了，而且你们不能退货，或者你们能吗？他引起了他们的注意。这和卖纸有什么关系。
paper. I don't know. But we had a huge fan catch from three people. Rebecca N., Evan H. and
Lauren B. all noticed that when Michael takes this pretend phone call, in the background, I clocked it
at 9 minutes, 39 seconds. You can see Utica's industrial printer is chained with a padlock.
Oh, no way. And there is a sign requesting employees to report
any suspicious behavior.
And this is a callback to the time that Michael and Dwight tried to steal Utica's printer
back in Branch Wars.
That's amazing.
我不知道。但我们收到了三个人的巨大粉丝发现。丽贝卡·N、埃文·H和劳伦·B都注意到，当迈克尔打这个假电话时，在背景里，我在9分39秒处记录到了。你可以看到尤蒂卡的工业打印机被挂锁锁住了。哦，不会吧。还有一个标志要求员工报告任何可疑行为。这是对迈克尔和德怀特在《分部战争》中试图偷回尤蒂卡打印机那次事件的回应。太神奇了。
That is amazing.
That is such a small detail.
I know.
And it's such a small thing.
Oh, I'm delighted by that.
I love that.
It's amazing.
Well, Karen, she has to say something.
太神奇了。那是一个非常小的细节。我知道。而且这是一件很小的事情。哦，我对此感到很高兴。我喜欢那个。太神奇了。好吧，凯伦，她必须说点什么。
Michael's being so ridiculous.
And she's like, Michael, this whole sort of shenanigan at the top here.
just makes us think you're a liar.
Mm-hmm.
And he's like, hold up.
Would a liar bring mini mounds bars?
And then you sadly throw them at everyone.
Okay.
迈克尔太荒谬了。她说，迈克尔，这里开始的整个这种恶作剧只会让我们觉得你是个骗子。嗯哼。他说，等等。骗子会带迷你杏仁巧克力棒吗？然后你悲伤地把它们扔给每个人。好的。
Jenna, there are a lot of bloopers of you doing this.
I know, because every time I did it, I would burst out laughing.
And I had many conversations with Ken Koppas and Mindy Kaling about this.
I had to sit there for a long time with these mini mounds bars in my hands.
Hiding them.
And Mindy thought it would be especially funny if I just did it very matter-factly.
And of course it was, and it made us laugh every time.
珍娜，有很多你做这个的花絮。我知道，因为每次我做的时候，我都会爆笑。我和肯·科帕斯还有明迪·卡灵谈过很多次。我不得不拿着这些迷你杏仁巧克力棒在手里坐很长时间。藏着它们。藏着它们。明迪认为如果我只是非常一本正经地做这件事会特别有趣。当然确实如此，这让我们每次都笑。
Sometimes I wouldn't even get to the throwing part.
Just me standing up, we would start laughing.
I mean, the mound's bars were getting very milty because I was holding them for so long.
The way you threw them was so awkward.
It was unnatural.
It hit people.
Yeah.
It's so funny.
有时候我甚至还没到扔的部分。只要我站起来，我们就会开始笑。我的意思是，杏仁巧克力棒变得非常融化，因为我拿了太久。你扔它们的方式太尴尬了。很不自然。它打到了人。是的。太搞笑了。
Well, Angela, this is also not the first time that Michael has thrown candy at people.
He loves to throw candy during a presentation.
If you remember in business school, he threw a bunch of candy at the students in Ryan's
business school class.
Yes, he loves to use candy to make a point about paper sales.
Well, I couldn't resist, Jenna.
When I heard mini mounds bars, I had to look up the origin of the mini mounds bar.
Oh, I'm fascinated.
好吧，安吉拉，这也不是迈克尔第一次向人们扔糖果了。他喜欢在演讲时扔糖果。如果你记得在商学院，他向瑞安商学院班的学生扔了一堆糖果。是的，他喜欢用糖果来强调纸张销售。好吧，我忍不住了，珍娜。当我听到迷你杏仁巧克力棒时，我不得不查一下迷你杏仁巧克力棒的起源。哦，我很着迷。
I love a mounds bar.
I ate many of the Mounds bars that day, I should say.
Are you Mounds Bar or Almond Joy?
No, no, no, no.
Okay.
Don't throw any nuts in my dark chocolate and coconut treat.
Can we play the jingle, please, that will live in your brain forever?
Sometimes you feel like a nut.
我喜欢杏仁巧克力棒。那天我吃了很多杏仁巧克力棒，我应该说。你是杏仁巧克力棒派还是开心乐园派？不，不，不，不。好的。别往我的黑巧克力和椰子点心里扔任何坚果。我们能播放那个永远活在你脑海里的广告歌吗？有时候你感觉像个坚果。
Sometimes you don't.
Almond Joy's got nuts.
Mounds don't.
Because sometimes you feel like a.
Sometimes you.
Yeah, I never feel like a nut.
You never feel like a nut.
No.
有时候你不觉得。开心乐园有坚果。杏仁巧克力棒没有。因为有时候你感觉像个。有时候你。是的，我从来没觉得像个坚果。你从来没觉得像个坚果。没有。
I am also a mini mounds bar person.
I love the dark chocolate.
I love it.
But let's start our story, guys.
How did we get the mini mounds bar?
Our story starts with Peter Paul Halogen.
He was a candy manufacturer in New Haven, Connecticut, in the early 20th century.
He was born in Armenia, and he immigrated to the U.S. in 1890 and opened a candy shop.
我也是迷你杏仁巧克力棒派。我喜欢黑巧克力。我喜欢它。但让我们开始我们的故事，伙计们。我们是怎么得到迷你杏仁巧克力棒的？我们的故事始于彼得·保罗·哈洛根。他是20世纪初康涅狄格州纽黑文市的一位糖果制造商。他出生在亚美尼亚，1890年移民到美国，开了一家糖果店。
He would sell candy bars to the U.S. Army, and they would sell candy bars to the U.S. Army, and they would
would put them in the soldiers' monthly rations during World War I. And then they loved the candy bar so
when they came home, they wanted more. So after the success of that, he teamed with five other
Armenian investors to form the Peter Paul Candy Manufacturing Company. They then made a very smart
purchase. They purchased a candy line from candy maker Vincent Natito, who created the original Mounds Bar.
He was selling it for five cents. Oh, full-size.
size. Five cents? They're not very big. But a full-size bar is two. He sold one. It was always a
mini. It was always a mini. Okay. And then Peter Paul actually just starts selling it in a pack of two for
他会把糖果棒卖给美国陆军，他们会把糖果棒卖给美国陆军，他们会把它们放在士兵第一次世界大战期间的每月配给中。然后他们喜欢上了这种糖果棒，所以当他们回家时，他们想要更多。所以在成功之后，他与另外五位亚美尼亚投资者合作成立了彼得·保罗糖果制造公司。他们随后进行了一次非常聪明的收购。他们从糖果制造商文森特·纳蒂托那里购买了一条糖果生产线，他创造了最初的杏仁巧克力棒。他以五美分的价格出售。哦，全尺寸。尺寸。五美分？它们不是很大。但全尺寸棒是两个。他卖了一个。它一直是个迷你的。它一直是个迷你的。好的。然后彼得·保罗实际上开始以两个一包的价格出售它，
10 cents. I wish you could see Angela's hands right now. I'm showing. Here, you want to take my pictures?
Yeah. I wanted to show Jenna what it would look like. Too many mounds bars. There it is.
Okay. Well, Jenna, during World War II, the Peter Paul Candy Manufacturing Company
was faced with a severe shortage of sugar and coconut, right?
Oh.
World War II, they had normally been shipped from the Philippines, then the war broke out.
So the company began sourcing coconut from the Caribbean using its own fleet of small vessels
to transport coconut supplies to the U.S.
10美分。我希望你们现在能看到安吉拉的手。我在展示。给你，你想拍我的照片吗？是的。我想给珍娜看看它看起来是什么样子的。太多的杏仁巧克力棒。就在那儿。好的。好吧，珍娜，在第二次世界大战期间，彼得·保罗糖果制造公司面临严重的糖和椰子短缺，对吧？哦。第二次世界大战，它们通常是从菲律宾运来的，然后战争爆发了。所以该公司开始使用自己的小型船队从加勒比海采购椰子，将椰子供应运往美国。
They were nicknamed the Mounds Flea Fleet.
There were about seven ships small enough to avoid detailed scrutiny by the German naval war vessels.
My gosh, all of this just to get coconut for some candy.
Wait, it gets better.
I have to say, if you're a ship captain during World War II,
are you risking your life to bring people coconut?
Hold up.
Okay, I guess you are.
它们被戏称为“杏仁巧克力棒跳蚤舰队”。大约有七艘船，小到足以避免德国海军战舰的详细审查。天哪，所有这些只是为了给一些糖果弄到椰子。等等，还有更好的。我必须说，如果你是第二次世界大战期间的船长，你会冒着生命危险给人们带椰子吗？等等。好的，我想你是。
Apparently, this flea fleet, as it was called...
F-L-E-E-E-E-L-E-A, a little flea fleet.
It's a little fleet.
It's a flea fleet.
Oh, it teeny tiny.
It's a tiny fleet.
Got it.
It was so small in size, it posed no.
显然，这个所谓的跳蚤舰队……F-L-E-E-E-E-L-E-A，一个小跳蚤舰队。它是一个小舰队。它是一个跳蚤舰队。哦，它非常小。它是一个微小的舰队。明白了。它体积太小，构不成。
threat to the German U-boats that were patrolling the Atlantic waters.
But what the German naval commanders did not know was that the crew of these vessels were also gathering more than coconuts.
They were gathering valuable intelligence about the Germans' fleet movements and sharing it with the American armed forces.
Wait one moment.
What you're telling me is that while collecting supplies to make one of my favorite candies,
Yeah.
These folks were also providing important war intelligence to the United States government during World War II.
对在大西洋水域巡逻的德国U型潜艇的威胁。但德国海军指挥官不知道的是，这些船只的船员收集的不仅仅是椰子。他们还在收集关于德国舰队动向的有价值的情报，并与美国武装部队分享。等一下。你告诉我的是，在收集制作我最喜欢的糖果之一的原料时，是的。这些人还在第二次世界大战期间向美国政府提供重要的战争情报。是的。
The mini Mounds Bar, I'm telling you, I was fascinated by all of this.
And they also dropped all of their other production of candies and just concentrated on the Mounds Bar because it was so popular.
And the U.S. military purchased as much as 80% of their output by 1944.
They would package 5 million candy bars monthly into combat.
rations. Wow. Yeah. And now, as we know, over the years, Peter Paul, they added several more
things to their line, including the Almond Joy, which they're often, you know, sold together.
But that's the story of the mini Mounds Bar. They're now owned by the Hershey Company. You can still
enjoy them today. Isn't that an amazing story? I would like to enjoy one today. So would I.
迷你杏仁巧克力棒，我告诉你们，我对这一切都很着迷。他们还放弃了所有其他糖果的生产，只专注于杏仁巧克力棒，因为它太受欢迎了。到1944年，美国军方购买了他们产量的80%。他们每月将500万根糖果棒包装成战斗口粮。哇。是的。现在，正如我们所知，多年来，彼得·保罗，他们又在产品线中增加了一些东西，包括开心乐园，它们通常，你知道，一起出售。但这就是迷你杏仁巧克力棒的故事。它们现在归好时公司所有。你今天仍然可以享受它们。这不是一个神奇的故事吗？我今天想享受一个。我也想。
The Mounds Flea Fleet. Wow. You guys, you can learn more about it at Connecticut History.
I have to say, I also love that it's an East Coast candy because it tracks with our show.
It does.
That Michael would be supporting something that originated in Connecticut.
Wow.
There you go.
I mean, what's fascinating?
The things you did not know you were going to learn today were that.
杏仁巧克力棒跳蚤舰队。哇。伙计们，你们可以在康涅狄格州历史频道了解更多。我必须说，我也喜欢它是一种东海岸糖果，因为它符合我们的节目。确实。迈克尔会支持起源于康涅狄格州的东西。哇。就是这样。我的意思是，什么很迷人？你今天不知道你会学到的事情就是那个。
I know.
I definitely was not expecting that.
Amazing.
This is another example of our offshoot podcast, Two Ladies Who Google.
Yes.
Two ladies who love to Google.
Google and tell you things.
Mm-hmm.
我知道。我绝对没想到会那样。神奇。这是我们衍生播客“两个爱谷歌的女士”的另一个例子。是的。两个喜欢谷歌的女士。谷歌并告诉你们事情。嗯哼。
We're fun at a dinner party, guys.
We actually are.
All right.
Michael has a talking head.
That is so good I texted it to Steve.
I don't know how he did it.
He explains he always wanted to become an actor, and he even has his own memorization
我们在晚宴上很有趣，伙计们。我们确实是。我们确实是。好吧。迈克尔有一个谈话头。太好了，我把它发短信给了史蒂夫。我不知道他是怎么做到的。他解释说他一直想成为一名演员，他甚至有自己的记忆
techniques.
Mm-hmm.
He explains that the way he learned the Pledge of Allegiance is by singing it to the tune of
Old McDonald.
Mm-hmm.
Steve then as Michael sings the Pledge of Allegiance to the tune of Old McDonald,
and I don't know how he did it.
I don't know how he did it.
技巧。嗯哼。他解释说他学习《效忠誓词》的方法是把它唱成《老麦克唐纳》的曲调。嗯哼。史蒂夫然后作为迈克尔唱《效忠誓词》到《老麦克唐纳》的曲调，我不知道他是怎么做到的。我不知道他是怎么做到的。
I texted to him and I said, this is an amazing performance.
This is so badass.
I mean, he does take a long pause.
This was in the script, by the way.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America
and to the Republic for which it stands.
One nation under God.
With a woof, wolf here.
我发短信给他，我说，这是一个神奇的表演。这太酷了。我的意思是，他确实停顿了很长时间。顺便说一下，这在剧本里。我效忠于美利坚合众国的国旗和它所代表的共和国。上帝之下的一个国家。汪，汪在这里。
rid of a little bit there. I mean, that is not easy to do. Well, it is true, you guys. You put something to a song and you'll
learn it. It's called a pneumonic device, and that's a real thing. It's a real thing. Michael says he uses it to
learn people's names. So what does he got here? He looks around the room. He's got shirdy,
mole, lazy eye, Mexico, baldy, sugar boobs, black woman. He said, I take a unique part of you,
and I use that to memorize your name.
Baldi, your head is bald.
It is hairless.
It is shiny.
在那里摆脱了一点点。我的意思是，这并不容易做到。好吧，这是真的，伙计们。你把东西编成歌，你就会学会它。这叫助记符，那是真实的东西。这是真实的东西。迈克尔说他用它来学习人们的名字。那么他在这里有什么？他环顾房间。他有衬衫、痣、懒眼、墨西哥、秃头、糖果胸、黑人女性。他说，我取你身上独特的一部分，我用它来记住你的名字。秃头，你的头是秃的。它是无毛的。它是闪亮的。
It is a reflective like a mirror M.
Your name is Mark.
And he says, yes.
Yes.
And Karen said, you know what?
This is all really offensive.
Guestar Alert, Mark, aka Baldi,
was played by Brian Patrick Mulligan.
它像镜子一样反射M。你的名字是马克。他说，是的。是的。凯伦说，你知道吗？这一切真的很冒犯人。客串警报，马克，又名秃头，由布莱恩·帕特里克·穆里根饰演。
He has an extensive career playing famous historical figures.
Like who?
Al Capone.
Oh.
Alfred Hitchcock.
Teddy Roosevelt.
He has played Ben Franklin in three different TV shows, including on Jimmy Kimmel Live.
He just played W.C. Fields in a movie.
他有扮演著名历史人物的丰富职业生涯。比如谁？阿尔·卡彭。哦。阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克。泰迪·罗斯福。他在三部不同的电视剧中扮演过本·富兰克林，包括在吉米·坎摩尔直播秀上。他刚在一部电影中扮演了W.C.菲尔兹。
But his most frequently played person is former vice president Dick Cheney.
Wow.
He has played Dick Cheney in six episodes of The Tonight Show with Jay Leno and 10 times on Jimmy Kimmel.
Those guys love bringing Dick Cheney on.
I guess so.
They love bringing Dick Cheney on.
Brian Patrick Mulligan on as Dick Cheney.
I also want you to know that mole did not have a real mole.
但他最常扮演的人是前副总统迪克·切尼。哇。他在六集《杰·雷诺今夜秀》和10次《吉米·坎摩尔秀》中扮演过迪克·切尼。那些家伙喜欢让迪克·切尼上节目。我想是吧。他们喜欢让迪克·切尼上节目。布莱恩·帕特里克·穆里根扮演迪克·切尼。我还想让你们知道痣不是真的痣。
Faky mole.
I know this because I saw the call sheet and he had to come in 15 minutes earlier than
everyone else to get that mole put on.
There you go.
Yeah.
So listen, back at Dunder Mifflin, I think we need to check in on Andy.
Yeah, he's fallen in love.
假痣。假痣。我知道这一点是因为我看到了通告单，他必须比其他人早15分钟来把那个痣贴上。就是这样。是的。所以听着，回到邓德·米夫林，我想我们需要看看安迪。是的，他坠入爱河了。
He has.
And he needs an in, right?
Before he goes and introduces himself to Julia, he's going to go down and he's going to
buy on her car to see if he can learn anything about her.
Got to get Intel.
So he's peering in her car and he sees that she has a Feist CD.
Oh, this is jackpot for him.
Jackpot.
他确实有。他需要一个切入点，对吧？在去向朱莉娅做自我介绍之前，他打算先去看看她的车，看看能不能打听到关于她的什么信息。得搞点情报。于是他往她车里瞧，发现她有一张Feist的CD。哦，这对他来说简直是中了大奖。大奖。
Then he sets off the car alarm.
And then another car alarm.
Yes.
Well, lady, do you remember this Feist song that he's going to sing later?
I do.
Huge.
It's called 1, 2, 3, 4.
So it was written by Leslie Feist, who went professionally
然后他触发了汽车警报。接着又触发了另一辆车的警报。是的。那么，这位女士，你还记得他后来要唱的那首Feist的歌吗？我记得。非常火。歌名叫《1, 2, 3, 4》。这首歌是由莱斯利·费斯特（Leslie Feist）创作的，她以艺名
as Feist. She's a Canadian pop singer. It came out in 2007. Anyway, I thought we should play the song
for everybody. Okay. Here is Feist, 1, 2, 3, 4.
One, two, three, four, tell me that you love me more. Sleepless, long nights as what my use was
for. Old teenage hopes or I let your door left you with...
It's so good. So, like Peppy.
The song was nominated for two Grammy Awards and Feist was nominated for Best New Artist and Best Pop Vocal album.
It was so huge, she did a spin on it for Sesame Street.
Okay, I didn't want to say anything, but this is where I remember it.
Feist出道。她是一位加拿大流行歌手。这首歌发行于2007年。总之，我觉得我们应该给大家放一下这首歌。好的。这就是Feist的《1, 2, 3, 4》。One, two, three, four, tell me that you love me more. Sleepless, long nights as what my use was for. Old teenage hopes or I let your door left you with... 太好听了。很有活力。这首歌获得了两项格莱美奖提名，Feist本人也获得了最佳新人奖和最佳流行演唱专辑奖提名。它当时太火了，她还为《芝麻街》做了一个改编版。好吧，我本来不想说什么，但这正是我对这首歌有印象的地方。
This was your Feist moment.
This was my Feist moment.
I mean, I actually feel like I heard it here first on Sesame Street, and then I was like, oh, that's what people are talking about.
Because Isabel loved Sesame Street.
Well, I pulled a clip of it on Sesame Street.
Oh, it's going to bring back all the feels for me.
I remember, oh, we watched this over and over.
We're going to learn to count, you guys, to the number four.
这就是你的Feist时刻。这就是我的Feist时刻。我是说，我真的觉得我是先在《芝麻街》里听到的，然后我就想，哦，原来这就是大家都在谈论的那首歌。因为伊莎贝尔很喜欢《芝麻街》。好吧，我找了一段她在《芝麻街》里的片段。哦，这会勾起我所有的回忆。我记得，哦，我们看了又看。我们要学数数了，伙计们，数到四。
One, two, three, four monsters walking across the floor.
I love counting, counting to the number four.
Oh, you're counting.
So one less.
Okay.
Why am I crying?
Oh, my gosh.
Because our kids were little.
One, two, three, four monsters walking across the floor. I love counting, counting to the number four. 哦，你在数数。少了一个。好吧。我为什么在哭？天哪。因为我们的孩子那时候还小。
and they love Sesame Street and they're older now.
I didn't even have a kid then.
But just I could hear the monsters start to sing.
I know.
There they all are.
And I don't know.
I know.
她们很喜欢《芝麻街》，现在她们都长大了。那时候我甚至还没生孩子。那时候我甚至还没生孩子。但只要听到那些怪物开始唱歌。我知道。它们都在那儿。我不知道。我知道。
You're right.
We don't watch Sesame Street anymore.
So maybe it just, I don't know.
I know.
Listen, I found a video where I, Isabel was little and I was doing Elmo.
And I was doing, I was like, I was going la la la la.
La La La La, La, Elmo's World.
Oh, yes.
你说得对。我们不再看《芝麻街》了。所以也许只是，我不知道。我知道。听着，我找到了一个视频，伊莎贝尔还小的时候，我在模仿艾摩。我在做，我在说，我在唱la la la la。La La La La, La, Elmo's World。哦，是的。
We sang that song all the time.
I know.
Yeah.
Let's have a baby.
No, I'm kidding.
Oh, my God.
I'm kidding.
我们总是唱那首歌。我知道。是啊。我们要个孩子吧。不，我开玩笑的。天哪。我开玩笑的。我开玩笑的。
No.
My daughter's been asking for a baby.
Oh, my gosh.
A little sister.
Listen, whenever I want to make my...
I didn't know how to explain periomenopause to her.
But I was like, Mama doesn't make any eggs anymore, baby.
Mama, let me, let's talk about cobwebs.
不。我女儿一直吵着要个小宝宝。天哪。想要个小妹妹。听着，每当我想让我的……我不知道该怎么向她解释围绝经期。但我当时说，妈妈不再排卵了，宝贝。妈妈，让我们，让我们谈谈蜘蛛网吧。
I want to describe you what a cobwebs.
situation is. Well, Andy is going to interrupt Stanley's meeting. He's going to bring them both some
coffees. He's put one, two, three, four splendas in Stanley's coffee. Yeah, he's like,
one, two, three, four splendas in your coffee, Stanley. None in yours, Julia, because I don't know
how you take it. I thought Julia was absolutely perfect. Oh, I did too. Guest our alert,
Julia was played by Erica Tazel.
I totally recognized her from the show Justified.
She played Rachel Brooks.
我想描述一下什么是蜘蛛网状况。嗯，安迪要去打断斯坦利的会议。他要给他们俩带些咖啡。他在斯坦利的咖啡里放了四包代糖。是的，他说，斯坦利，你的咖啡里放了四包代糖。朱莉娅，你的没放，因为我不知道你喜欢怎么喝。我觉得朱莉娅简直太完美了。哦，我也这么觉得。客串嘉宾提醒，朱莉娅由埃里卡·塔泽尔（Erica Tazel）饰演。我完全认出她是在《火线警探》里。她饰演瑞秋·布鲁克斯。
Erica is a classically trained actress.
She graduated with an MFA from the NYU acting program.
Her professional acting debut was at the New York Shakespeare Festival.
And since we've been tracking these things,
I'll have you know she was not on Monk,
but she has been on both Law and Order and Law & Order Special Victims Unit.
I loved all of her reactions to Andy.
They were so perfect.
埃里卡是一位受过古典训练的演员。她毕业于纽约大学表演系，获得艺术硕士学位。她的职业表演首秀是在纽约莎士比亚节。既然我们一直在追踪这些，我得告诉你，她没演过《神探阿蒙》，但她演过《法律与秩序》和《法律与秩序：特殊受害者》。我喜欢她对安迪的所有反应。它们太完美了。
And this whole thing has just completely ticked off Stanley.
He's like, what are you doing?
He pulls Andy aside.
And Andy says he loves Julia with all his heart.
Yeah.
All his heart.
Stanley is like, if you really love her, fine.
Give me two of your clients.
而这一切彻底惹恼了斯坦利。他心想，你在干什么？他把安迪拉到一边。安迪说他全心全意地爱着朱莉娅。是的。全心全意。斯坦利说，如果你真的爱她，行。把你的两个客户给我。
You can have this client.
Yeah.
So Andy takes over the meeting in a very awkward way.
Mm-hmm.
He wonders, where should we send?
Your invoices.
To your boyfriend?
Right.
你可以接手这个客户。是的。于是安迪以一种非常尴尬的方式接管了会议。嗯。他想知道，我们应该把发票寄到哪里？寄给你男朋友吗？对。
Because we certainly could.
And she's so matter-effectily, he's like, no, you can send it to my work address.
This is for work.
Yeah.
But Andy does find out she does not have a boyfriend.
And then he kind of panics.
He's so excited.
And then he gets advice from Creed.
因为我们确实可以。而她非常公事公办地说，不，你可以寄到我的工作地址。这是为了工作。是的。但安迪确实发现她没有男朋友。然后他有点慌了。他太兴奋了。然后他从克里德那里得到了建议。
Why, Creed?
I don't know, but I'm...
Why would you go to Creed for advice?
Creed's like, say no more.
Just go in for a kiss?
That's how I got squeaky from.
Yeah.
I didn't know who that was.
为什么是克里德？我不知道，但我……你为什么要去找克里德寻求建议？克里德说，别说了。直接去亲她？我就是这么搞定斯奎基（Squeaky）的。是的。我不知道那是谁。
I had to Google it.
Oh, you didn't know who it was?
No.
Yeah.
Now I do.
Well, Charles Manson.
She was part of the Manson family.
我不得不去谷歌搜索。哦，你不知道那是谁？不知道。是的。现在我知道了。是的。嗯，查尔斯·曼森。她是曼森家族的一员。
Right.
Yeah.
She went to jail.
She tried to assassinate Gerald Ford.
Right.
Mm-hmm.
She was not part of the Tate La Bianca murders, but she did try to assassinate Gerald Ford.
对。是的。她坐过牢。她试图刺杀杰拉尔德·福特。对。对。嗯。她不是泰特-拉比安卡谋杀案的参与者，但她确实试图刺杀杰拉尔德·福特。
So I guess Creed kissed her.
And he says, have I ever steered you wrong, Jim?
Yeah, just go in and kiss her.
just do it.
That just, you know, that's what you should do.
When he called Andy Jim, if you're Andy, wouldn't you think, hmm, there's many reasons
to red flags.
There's so many red flags.
所以我猜克里德亲了她。他说，我什么时候误导过你吗，吉姆？是的，直接去亲她。就这么做。那只是，你知道，那是你应该做的。当他叫安迪为吉姆时，如果你是安迪，难道你不觉得，嗯，有很多理由说明这是危险信号吗？有太多的危险信号了。
So many red flags.
Well, for whatever reason, Andy is going to take Creed's advice.
He's going to walk Julia to the car.
He forgot his coat.
Could he run back in and get it real quick?
Because he's very, very cold.
Julia says my car's right here, I think.
Thanks for walking me down.
太多的危险信号。好吧，不管出于什么原因，安迪打算听从克里德的建议。他要送朱莉娅去车上。他忘了拿外套。他能跑回去快速拿一下吗？因为他非常非常冷。朱莉娅说我想我的车就在这儿。谢谢你送我下来。
But I'm good.
and then when he gets her to the car, he goes in for a kiss, Andy.
Come on.
This woman has had to put up with so much in this meeting, and now this.
Also, like, she could write him up.
I know.
He could lose his job, Andy.
Don't listen to Creed, Andy.
但我没事。然后当他把她送到车边时，他直接去亲她，安迪。拜托。这个女人在会议中已经忍受了这么多，现在又来这一出。而且，她可以举报他。我知道。他可能会丢掉工作，安迪。别听克里德的，安迪。
They do lose the account.
Yeah.
He has a talking head.
So he kind of lost in every way today.
He lost three accounts.
He lost two that he gave to Stanley.
Oh, yeah.
that Stanley gave to him, and he kind of showed his ass.
他们确实丢掉了那个客户。是的。他有一个采访镜头。所以他今天在各方面都输了。他丢了三个客户。他丢了两个他给斯坦利的。哦，是的。斯坦利给他的，他有点自取其辱。
Yeah, yeah, he did.
Well, speaking of showing your ass, Karen has asked Michael to leave the conference room and come to her office.
It's like getting called to the principal's office.
And he is trying very hard to explain that he had a whole bit with a chainsaw that he hasn't been able to do.
And Karen's like, you know what?
Why don't you just put it all in an email?
And I'll send it to my team.
And he's like, I can't put a chainsaw in an email, Karen.
是的，是的，他确实。说到自取其辱，凯伦让迈克尔离开会议室去她的办公室。这就像被叫到校长办公室一样。他非常努力地解释他有一个关于电锯的梗，但他一直没机会表演。凯伦说，你知道吗？你为什么不把它写在邮件里？我会发给我的团队。他说，我不能把电锯放进邮件里，凯伦。
I can't do it.
This is when Pam and Karen are going to have a little bonding moment.
Yeah.
It's so sweet.
Pam says, when are you due?
And Karen says, I'm doing a month.
Yeah.
Michael says, who did this to you?
我做不到。这是帕姆和凯伦要进行一点联谊时刻的时候。是的。太甜了。帕姆说，你预产期是什么时候？凯伦说，我还有一个多月。是的。迈克尔说，是谁对你做了这种事？
Who did this to you, Karen?
She's like, my husband.
He's a dermatologist.
We met at a bar.
And then they have all these cute photos.
They have one where they're dressed like hot dogs.
Yes, a hot dog and a hamburger.
It's very cute.
是谁对你做了这种事，凯伦？她说，我丈夫。他是皮肤科医生。我们在酒吧认识的。然后他们有很多可爱的照片。他们有一张照片是打扮成热狗的样子。是的，一个热狗和一个汉堡。非常可爱。
We had a lot of fan questions about this.
Everyone wants to know who is the man in the photo.
Who is Dan, the dermatologist, who is married to Karen?
Well, it was played by writer Dan Gore.
Yeah.
He was a writer on Parks and Recreation.
Yes, and he had been working with Mike Scher and Greg Daniels
as they developed that show.
我们收到了很多粉丝关于这个的问题。每个人都想知道照片里的男人是谁。谁是丹，那个和凯伦结婚的皮肤科医生？嗯，他是由编剧丹·戈尔（Dan Gore）饰演的。是的。他是《公园与游憩》的编剧。是的，他在开发那部剧时一直和迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）以及格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）一起工作。
and we had seen him a few times on set and in the writer's room meeting with those guys.
And he came to set one day when we were shooting on the stages,
and he and Rashida dressed up in all these different outfits,
and they went around and took pictures.
It was amazing.
Well, you know, now Karen is going to ask about Jim.
Yes.
我们曾在片场和编剧室见过他几次，他和那些人开会。有一天我们在摄影棚拍摄时他来到片场，他和拉什达（Rashida）穿上各种不同的服装，到处拍照。太棒了。太棒了。嗯，你知道，现在凯伦要问关于吉姆的事了。是的。
It's a little bit of tension, but Pam says we're engaged.
And Karen is just earnestly happy.
for them.
Yeah.
Rashida really sold it.
Because I think as an audience, you're like, oh, what's the?
And she's like, she has so moved on.
She has a whole life.
有一点紧张，但帕姆说我们订婚了。凯伦是真诚地为他们感到高兴。是的。拉什达演得真好。因为我觉得作为观众，你会想，哦，这是什么？而她就像是，她已经完全走出来了。她有自己的生活。
She's happy and it gives Pam closure.
Yeah.
I don't know about you, Ang, but I am happy if someone I have broken up with finds like a new relationship with someone else and they're in love.
Because I'm like, yeah, that's why we broke.
up because we weren't a match and then you found your match. I don't have a lot of hard feelings
about stuff. And I've had some messy breakups, you know? And even still, I don't know. I just,
I think I am more Karen on this one. I'm like, well, great. I'm glad that worked out because,
you know, good. It wasn't meant to be for me and Jim, but it's for you and Jim. Right. No, I think
她很幸福，这给了帕姆一个了结。是的。我不知道你怎么样，安吉，但我很高兴如果我分手的人找到了新的伴侣并且相爱了。因为我会想，是的，这就是我们分手的原因，因为我们不合适，然后你找到了你的另一半。我对这些事情没有太多的怨恨。即使我经历过一些糟糕的分手，你知道吗？即便如此，我不知道。我只是，我想我在这一点上更像凯伦。我会想，嗯，太好了。我很高兴事情进展顺利，因为，你知道，很好。我和吉姆注定无缘，但你和吉姆是天作之合。对。不，我觉得
life is short. My grandmother used to always say every pot has its lid. And I want to
everyone to find their lid. Yeah. I wasn't your lid. I fell in the water. Or I was too big. I was too big for your pot.
Yeah. Or too small for your pot. I didn't fit your pot. Let's break it down some more. I'm trying to see if
that's what she said in there, but I can't find it. My lid fit your pot perfect? No. I think it would be
your pot fit my lid just right. That's what she said. I don't think either of them are real strong. That's
She says.
We should let it go.
No, let's stick with it.
人生苦短。我祖母过去常说，锅配锅盖。我希望每个人都能找到自己的锅盖。是的。我不是你的锅盖。我掉进水里了。或者我太大了。我对于你的锅来说太大了。是的。或者对于你的锅来说太小了。我不适合你的锅。让我们再深入分析一下。我试着看看她是不是那么说的，但我找不到。我的锅盖完美契合你的锅？不。我觉得应该是你的锅完美契合我的锅盖。她是那么说的。我觉得这两个都不太准确。那是她说的。我们应该放过它。不，让我们坚持下去。
No, let's try it.
Let's try a few more.
We'll find it.
Everyone, if you find it, will you email us?
Oh, no.
What are you asking for?
不，让我们试试。让我们再试几次。让我们再试几次。我们会找到的。我们会找到的。大家，如果你们找到了，能给我们发邮件吗？哦，不。你在要求什么？
I don't know.
All right.
Some interesting mail to read.
That's for sure.
I don't know where we are.
We've hopped around.
Well, I'll tell you.
我不知道。好吧。有一些有趣的邮件要读。那是肯定的。那是肯定的。我不知道我们在哪儿。我们跳来跳去的。嗯，我告诉你。
Okay.
Michael and Pam are going to leave the Utica branch.
All right.
Michael gives his lecture a B.
Plus, he says Karen is mean.
Aw, Pam says I like her.
And then Pam says she's glad she came along
and that seeing Karen gave her closure.
好的。迈克尔和帕姆要离开尤蒂卡分部了。好的。迈克尔给他的讲座打了B+，他说凯伦很刻薄。噢，帕姆说我喜欢她。然后帕姆说她很高兴她一起来了，看到凯伦给了她一个了结。
Well, that's going to come back
because as they're driving away,
Michael tells Pam, you know what?
I never got closure with Holly.
She was the love of my life and I never got closure.
So Pam says, I think we should blow off.
this lecture in Rochester and go to Nashua instead. Michael says, let's do it. Pam's like, yeah, screw
them. Let's do this. All of a sudden, Michael just got, what do the kids call it, a ride or die.
嗯，这会回来的，因为当他们开车离开时，迈克尔告诉帕姆，你知道吗？我从来没有和霍莉有个了结。她是我的挚爱，我从来没有得到过一个了结。所以帕姆说，我觉得我们应该翘掉罗切斯特的讲座，直接去纳舒厄。迈克尔说，干吧。帕姆说，是的，去他们的。我们干吧。突然之间，迈克尔就有了，孩子们管这叫什么，生死与共。
He's like, yeah. Yeah, and then we have to be continued. Yeah, screen goes to black. You think it's over,
but there's a tag. There's a tag. Jim is asking Creed for $3 for Kelly's party.
Crete says great. I'd like to contribute. And then he hands him a $3 bill.
Mm-hmm. I had to know whose face was on that $3 bill. Okay.
Because, you know, Phil Shea had to make that. Yeah. I paused. I looked at it. You know who I thought it was?
Who? Brad Pitt.
No. It looked like Brad Pitt to me. And I thought maybe it was a nod to BJ because he was doing the movie with Brad Pitt.
Oh. I don't know. I remember we talked.
他说，是的。是的，然后我们不得不未完待续。是的，屏幕变黑了。你以为结束了，但还有一个彩蛋。有一个彩蛋。吉姆正在向克里德要3美元作为凯利的派对费用。克里德说太好了。我想捐款。然后他递给他一张3美元的钞票。嗯。我必须知道那张3美元钞票上是谁的脸。好的。因为，你知道，菲尔·谢（Phil Shea）必须制作那个。是的。我暂停了。我看了看。你知道我以为是谁吗？谁？布拉德·皮特。不。对我来说看起来像布拉德·皮特。我以为这可能是对BJ的一个致敬，因为他当时正在和布拉德·皮特拍电影。哦。我不知道。我记得我们谈论过
a lot about Brad Pitt when BJ was making that movie. We all thought we might become friends with him.
We were positive. We were like, BJ, bring him to set. Maybe he's like to come have lunch.
Yeah. We'll be totally cool, BJ. We will be normal. Exactly. Remember we went through-
that with John and George Clooney, too. We're like, John, we're going to be so normal around George.
We're not going to bring up, you know, his place in Lake Como and that we want to go.
We've read about it. We won't say that. We won't say that we read about it in People magazine.
We won't say any of those things.
None of those things.
很多关于布拉德·皮特的事，当BJ在拍那部电影时。我们都以为我们可能会和他成为朋友。我们很确定。我们当时说，BJ，带他来片场。也许他喜欢来吃午饭。是的。我们会表现得非常酷，BJ。我们会很正常的。正是。记得我们也经历过约翰和乔治·克鲁尼的事吗？我们当时说，约翰，我们在乔治面前会表现得非常正常。我们不会提起，你知道，他在科莫湖的房子，以及我们想去。我们读到过。我们不会说。我们不会说我们在《人物》杂志上读到过。我们不会说任何那些事情。什么都不说。
Well, it turns out Randy Cordray told me who's on the $3 bill.
Who?
George W. Bush.
What?
I don't know.
That's who Phil picked.
He said Phil made it, and that's who he put on it.
You thought George W. Bush was Brad Pitt?
嗯，结果兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）告诉我3美元钞票上是谁。谁？乔治·W·布什。什么？我不知道。那是菲尔选的人。他说菲尔制作了它，那就是他放上去的人。你以为乔治·W·布什是布拉德·皮特？
I guess I did.
It's time for new glasses.
Get Nana some glasses.
You guys, that's lecture circuit part one.
Yep.
We'll be back next week with lecture circle.
at part two and a lot of stories about licking cats.
You said that so Midwest and a lot of stories about licking cats.
我想我是那么以为的。是时候换副新眼镜了。给奶奶配副眼镜。伙计们，这就是《讲座巡回》第一部分。是的。下周我们将带着《讲座巡回》第二部分回来，还有很多关于舔猫的故事。你说的太有中西部特色了，还有很多关于舔猫的故事。
Yeah.
Sometimes your Missouri really comes out and I live for it.
Oh, here I'll give you some Missouri.
One, two, three, far.
Far!
We're counting to far.
Oh, uh-oh.
是的。有时候你的密苏里口音真的显露出来了，我太喜欢了。哦，来，我给你来点密苏里味儿。One, two, three, far. Far! 我们数到far。我们数到far。哦，啊哦。
We're counting.
Too far.
There you go.
See you guys next week.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' second drink.
This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
我们在数数。太远了。好了。下周见，伙计们。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔（Matt Beagle）。
Our Second Drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent.
Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schult.
Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton.
我们的《第二杯》剧集由莫莉·纽金特（Molly Nugent）制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。Odyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔特（Bill Schult）混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Ruppertree》。